चलिए तो फाइनली हम लाइव आ चुके हैं एंड
लेट मी सेट अप माय स्क्रीन यर चलिए आप लोग
मुझे बता दीजिए एक बार जल्दी से कि ऑडिबल
एंड विजिबल आवाज सब कुछ सही है ऑडियो
वीडियो एवरीथिंग इ गुड जल्दी बता द जल्दी
बताए जल्दी बताइए फटाफट बताइए गुड इवनिंग
गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग बढ़िया बढ़िया एकदम
बढ़िया आप लोग बताओ एकदम बढ़िया
चलिए ओके ऑडिबल एकदम क्लियर ऑडियो है ना
भाई ठीक है हां जी हां जी हां जी हां जी
हां जी राम राम जी राम राम
जी ठीक है बढ़िया रोड टू 20 के हां जी रोड
टू 20 के बिल्कुल बिल्कुल सो बहुत जल्द हम
20 के डिफर स्टर्स होने वाले हैं एज यू
कैन सी नाउ कि हमारे
19.9 के करेंटली जो हमारे सब्सक्राइबर्स
हैं फिलहाल एंड बहुत जल्द 20 के होने वाले
हैं एंड लिंकन पे भी आप सब देख रहे होंगे
9707 फॉलोअर्स काउंट हो चुके हैं तो यह भी
10 के जल्दी होने वाला है अब देखना है कि
पहले youtube1 या हमारा
बेसिकली क्या है कि सिर्फ 20 या 25
सब्सक्राइबर्स ही हैं कम जो 20 20 के होने
में तो यह पहले हो जाएगा इसमें तो अभी 300
है तो चलिए बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद आप लोगों का
एंड
हां भैया मैं वीडियो 15 पे हूं तो क्या
पहले का कवर के साथ-साथ लाइव चल सकता हूं
बिल्कुल चल सकते हो लाइव में पहले के
साथ-साथ चल सकते हो बिल्कुल चल सकते हो
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है तो सब लोगों को आ
जाने देते हैं जल्दी से ए एंड जैसा कि
मैंने आपको बताया हुआ है कि हर वीडियो जो
भी लाइव वीडियोस होती हैं आप सबके की आप
किसी भी वीडियो को ओपन कर लीजिएगा एंड उस
वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में चले जाइएगा
जैसे कि मैं यहां पे आपको दिखा देता हूं अ
ये रही डिस्क्रिप्शन तो डिस्क्रिप्शन में
आपको एक हमारा
whatsapp2 एंड ग्रुप जो चैनल है डिफ्रॉक
साइबर वरियर्स जहां पे 4500 के आसपास
हमारे साइबर वरियर्स जुड़े हुए हैं जहां
पर आपको सबसे पहले अपडेट्स जो है वो मिल
जाती हैं तो इसको जवाइन जरूर कर लीजिएगा
ठीक है चलिए तो स्टार्ट करेंगे बट उसके
पहले अ एक इंपॉर्टेंट चीज मैं आपको बता
देता हूं कि जब भी आप बग बाउंट कर रहे हैं
जो आप बग हंटिंग कर रहे हैं तो आप रिवॉर्ड
पे और सिर्फ
बाउंटीज इसका एक बहुत बड़ा रीजन है बताने
का फिर से दोहराने का क्योंकि अ कुछ
मैसेजेस आते हैं मेरे पास कि सर हम इतने
टाइम से दो महीने हो गए हैं या एक महीने
से मैं हंट कर रहा हूं सर हमें बाउंट नहीं
लग रही है बाउंट हमें नहीं मिल रही है
बताओ सर क्या करें बताओ क्या प्रॉब्लम हो
रही है भाई कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं हो रही है
सीधा जवाब है कोई भी इशू नहीं है कोई भी
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है सिंपल सा है कि आपको
बाउंट लगेगी वेट फॉर सम टाइम एंड कीप
प्रैक्टिसिंग कीप हसंग कीप फाइंडिंग कीप
ग्रिडिंग आप करते रहो ना यार आप ट्राई
करते रहो बाउंट लगेगी पहले ही हार मान
लोगे कि नहीं बाउंट अभी एक महीना हो गया
दो महीना हो गया आई हैव सीन रिसर्चस अ
स्पेंडिंग सिक्स मंथ्स टू वन ईयर टू हाफ
एन ईयर टू गेट देयर फर्स्ट एवर बाउंटीज
उनको मिल जाती है उसके बाद वो जल्दी रुकते
नहीं है दे कैन नॉट बी स्टॉप्ड बिकॉज़
उनको ना वो की मेथड उनकी खुद की डेवलप हो
चुकी होती है उनको पता चल गया होता है कि
भैया कैसे मिलेगी बाउंट एंड ये एक ऐसी चीज
है एक ऐसा आर्ट है ना मैं आपको सच बता रहा
हूं दिस इज अ काइंड ऑफ आर्ट कि अगर आप एक
बार सीख चुके ना तो आप उसमें मास्टर बनते
जाओगे धीरे-धीरे एंड आपको किसी की जरूरत
नहीं पड़ेगी फिर एंड मेरा भी गाइडेंस वहां
पर कंप्लीट हो जाएगा जब आप बाउंटीज लेना
स्टार्ट कर दोगे एंड यू विल कीप गेटिंग
बाउंटीज ऑन फ्रीक्वेंसी इट्स माय गारंटी
टू यू बस आप लगे रहो बस ट्स इट ठीक
[संगीत]
है ओके गट इट
चलिए गुड
इवनिंग कवल जीत सिंह बढ़िया इंडस्ट्रियल
ट्रेनिंग कब से स्टार्ट होगा बहुत जल्द
स्टार्ट होगा मेडी इंडस्ट्रियल ट्रेनिंग
बहुत जल्द स्टार्ट होगा अगर जिनको नहीं
पता तो मैं आपको बता देता हूं एक हम बहुत
ही इंटरेस्टिंग जो है ना एक वीपीटी का
वीपीटी का एक
इंडस्ट्रियल
ट्रेनिंग कम
इंटर्नशिप प्रोग्राम लेकर आ रहे हैं ठीक
है अब यह एक्चुअल इंडस्ट्रियल ट्रेनिंग
एंड इंटर्नशिप होगी यानी कि आपको वो चीजें
सिखाई जाएंगी जो इंडस्ट्री में वी एपीटीसी
तरीके से किया जाता है ना वनबिल असेसमेंट
एंड पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग जिस तरीके से
परफॉर्म किया जाता है उस तरीके से आपको इस
पूरी ट्रेनिंग में आपको सिखाया जाएगा एंड
उसके साथ ही आपको एक इंटर्नशिप कराई जाएगी
जहां आपसे आपको कुछ प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम्स
आपको दिए जाएंगे कुछ तरीके आपको बताए
जाएंगे कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग वेज आपको बताया
जाएगा जी सी जीरो डे कैसे फाइंड करते हैं
सीवीज कैसे आप अपने नाम पर रजिस्टर करा
सकते हैं आप सबने सुना होगा ना सीवीज का
नाम सीवीज सब कोई हर किसी ने सुना है ना
सीवीज यह
बताइए यह बताइए यह यह लाइव पेड ट्रेनिंग
आने वाली है इट विल नॉट बी फ्री फ्री नहीं
होगा एंड इंडस्ट्री का एक बहुत ही
एक्सपर्ट बंदा जो 3 साल से ऊपर काम कर रहा
है एक एमएनसी में काम कर रहा है वो बंदा
आपको कराएगा पूरा
कंप्लीट तो सीवीज या सीवीज आपको को पता है
ठीक है जीरो डे पता है सबको व्हाट इज जीरो
डे एवरीवन
नो हां आउट ऑफ इंडिया के लिए भी है किसी
के लिए भी है बस हिंदी आनी
चाहिए ठीक है रिपोर्ट राइटिंग की वीडियो
में लेकर
आऊंगा जी हां तो जो आपका यह जीरो डे
लेबिलिटी है ना इसको भी फाइंड करने के
आपको बताए जाएंगे तरीके कि जीरो डे कैसे
फाइंड किए जाते हैं नॉर्मल बाउंटीज नॉर्मल
बग वगैरह तो कोई भी फाइंड कर लेगा कोई भी
सीख सकता है सीख के फाइंड कर लेगा ज़ीरो
डे फाइंड करना भी एक आर्ट ही है ज़ीरो डे
फाइंड किया खुद के नाम पे सीवी रजिस्टर
किया तो दिस इज अ वेरी बिग अचीवमेंट तो
आपको वो एक बंदा कराएगा जो ऑलरेडी उसके
नाम पे सीवीज हैं जिसको अ
google's एंड वर्किंग इन एन एमएनसी तो वो
बहुत ही एडवांस चीजें होंगी लाइक थोड़ा
आपका उसका प्री रिक्विजिट यही होगा कि आप
यह बग बाउंट की सीरीज जो हैना इसको फॉलो
करते हो उसमें कोई भी ऐसा नहीं आ सकता कि
बिल्कुल नहीं आता हो तो आपके लिए वो नहीं
होगी वीपीटी की ट्रेनिंग स्पेशली जो
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल कुछ नहीं नॉलेज है तो
नहीं होगा आपके लिए वो अगर हल्का फुल्का
बेसिक नॉलेज है तो आपके लिए वो रहेगा फिर
यू कैन जॉइन ठीक
है ओके एंड जो ट्रेनिंग की ड्यूरेशन होगी
फोर टू सिक्स मंथ्स की ट्रेनिंग की
ड्यूरेशन होगी मतलब चार से छ महीने की फोर
टू सिक्स मंथ्स के बीच हम उसको खत्म
करेंगे हो सकता है चार महीने में हो या 5च
महीने या 6 महीने में लग जाए ठीक है
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल चलिए तो आज की सेशन को हम
स्टार्ट करते हैं आज का सेशन जो है बहुत
ही एक इंटरेस्टिंग सेशन है आप सबको पता
होगा कि वर्डप्रेस हंटिंग का डे 40 है
जहां पे हम थोड़े से एडवांस अ चीजें जो
हैं करने वाले हैं वर्डप्रेस हंटिंग के
अंदर में एंड कुछ चीजें हम सीखने वाले हैं
ठीक है तो प्रीवियस सेशन में मैंने आपको
बहुत सारी चीजें वर्डप्रेस हंटिंग के ऊपर
बताई हुई थी सीएमए मैप टूल का यूज़ करना
डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन टू का यूज़ करना यह सब
चीज बताया हुआ था ईमानदारी से ऑनेस्टली
बता दीजिए मुझे आप लोग में से कितने लोगों
ने वर्डप्रेस हंटिंग वाली क्लास के बाद
वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट्स खोज के एंड उस पे हंट
करके प्रैक्टिस करा था सीएमएस और
डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन का यूज करके ईमानदारी से
बताना जो है वही बताना चलिए
[संगीत]
बताइए बताइए प्लीज यस कपिल पटेल अ डेफॉक्स
पे ही आएगी अकेडमी पे अनाउंसमेंट प्लीज आप
उसमें आ सकते हो
ओके ओके ठीक है कोई बात
[संगीत]
नहीं यस सर मैंने मैनुअल किया था चलिए
अच्छी बात
है ओके सयस क्या बात है सयस कांग्रेचुलेशन
सयस फॉर फाइंडिंग अ वैलिड बग इन हैकर
वन प्रैक्टिस किया था बहुत लोगों ने नहीं
किया था ना कुछ लोगों ने किया भी था कुछ
बहुत लोगों ने नहीं भी किया था राइट
चलो कोई बात नहीं अब इसमें मैं कुछ नहीं
कर सकता ब जिनके अंदर जुनून है पैशन है वह
तो करेंगे उनको बोलने की भी जरूरत नहीं है
दे विल डू देम सेल्स
ओके ठीक है
ललित ठीक है ओके लेट्स क्राफ्ट ओके हैक
स्किल्स ठीक है मोहम्मद
कासिम आदित्य ठीक है ओके जस गेमर
जस ना लर्निंग फम प्रीवियस एपिसोड्स हां
आई एम आप प्रीवियस भी देख सकते हो यह भी
देख सकते हो अलग-अलग है ठीक है वर्डप्रेस
का अगर देखा नहीं होगा तो वो देख लेना
चलिए सो आज गाइस हम करने वाले हैं बात
एक्सएमएल
आरपीसी के ऊपर में थोड़ा सा डिटेल में हम
इस पर बात करने वाले हैं एक्सएमएल आरपीसी
के ऊपर में ठीक है क्या है किस तरीके से
मैंने आपको पहले की सेशन में आपको बताया
था कि एक्सएमएल आरपीसी नाम की एक फाइल
होती है एंड एक बेसिकली एक यूटिलिटी है
जिसके थ्रू वर्डप्रेस की साइट
से हम कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं किसी भी थर्ड
पार्टी एप्लीकेशन को उससे कनेक्ट करा सकते
हैं इसका सिंपल सा एक्सएमएल का मतलब होता
है एक्सटेंसिबल मार्क अप लैंग्वेज
एक्सएमएल एक लैंग्वेज है और कुछ भी नहीं
है अगर आपको नहीं पता तो मैं आपको यहां पर
लेट मी शो
यू जस्ट
वेट ठीक है तो
ओके सो मैं यहां पे एक्सएमए की ट्यूटोरियल
ओपन करके दिखा देता हूं जिनको एक्सए के
बारे में जानकारी लेनी होगी फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट
एकदम फ्री बिल्कुल बहुत ही शानदार
ट्यूटोरियल आपको w3 स्कूल्स पे मिल जाएगा
बहुत ही इजी टू लर्न लैंग्वेज है बहुत इजी
सिंटेक्स है बहुत इजी है आप यहां से आके
इसको सीख सकते हैं कि क्या होता है
एक्सएमए एक्सएमए का मतलब वही होता है
एक्सटेंसिबल मार्कअप लैंग्वेज ठीक है तो
एक्सएमए आरपीसी यानी एक्सटेंसिबल मार्कअप
लैंग्वेज रिमोट प्रोसीजर कॉल ठीक है
आरपीसी रिमोट प्रोसीजर कॉल एक तरह से हम
कनेक्ट करते हैं रिमोट होस्ट से बाहर के
किसी भी थर्ड पार्टी से कनेक्ट कर सकते
हैं अब यह बस सोचो यह बस इमेजिन करो कि
अगर हम एक्सएमएल आरपीसी के थ्रू किसी
वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट से किसी भी तरह से अगर
इंटरेक्ट कर पा रहे हैं दैट मींस दैट
वेबसाइट कैन बी वल्नरेबल अब वह वल्नरेबल
कितना ज्यादा इंपैक्ट कर रही है उस
वेबसाइट को डिपेंड करता है कि एक्सएमएल
आरपीसी के थ्रू जितने भी मेथड्स हम यूज कर
पा रहे हैं अलग-अलग मेथड्स होते हैं जिसको
हम यूज कर सकते हैं तो उनमें से कितने
मेथड्स को हम एक्चुअली एग्जीक्यूट कर पा
रहे हैं एंड कितने मेथड से हम क्या-क्या
चीजें कर पा रहे हैं अब इसका यूज एक्सएमएल
आरपीसी अगर एक्सप्लॉयड की बात करें या
वनबिल की हम बात करते हैं तो इसका यूज
क्या कर सकते हैं हम ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक
करने में कर सकते हैं उस वर्डप्रेस
वेबसाइट पे ब्रूट फोर्स वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट
इसमें कर सकते हैं दूसरा यूज हम क्या कर
सकते हैं इसमें हम डॉस अटैक कर सकते हैं
उस पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट के ऊपर में दिस इज अ
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग मतलब ब्रूट ब्रूट
फोर्स आप यूजरनेम पासवर्ड का कर सकते हैं
यहां पे आप डॉट्स अटैक कर सकते हैं देयर
आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स दैट कैन बी डन आप
यूजर्स लिस्ट कर सकते
हैं लिस्ट यूजर्स तो आप यूजर्स फाइंड कर
सकते हैं इफ देयर इज दैट पर्टिकुलर
अवेलेबिलिटी एंड यू कैन फाइंड एंड यू कैन
गेट डिटेल्स ऑफ डिफरेंट डिफरेंट थिंग्स तो
इसको हम जब प्रैक्टिकली थोड़ा करके
देखेंगे तब हम समझेंगे कि एक्चुअली यह चीज
है क्या एंड काम कैसे करती है चलिए तो अब
अब हम क्या करते हैं गाइस लेट्स गो टू अ
टारगेट तो यहां पे टारगेट फाइंड करने के
लिए सिंपल सा एक तरीका है आप वह तरीका यूज
कर सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है जैसे कि
मैं यहां पे कर देता हूं एक्सएमएल आर पीसी
एक्सप्लोइट आप सर्च कर सकते हैं यहां पे
एंड यहां पे लेट्स गो टू गब यहां पे कोई
भी एक लाइक
इफ यू वांट जैसे कि यहां पे
google.com तो ये हमने ओपन कर लिया एक यह
वेबसाइट है kct.ac.in अच्छी बात है अ और
भी कोई वेबसाइट है क्या क block.com इसको
ओपन कर लेते हैं अ व्हाट इज दिस अ दिस इज
आल्सो नेशनल इंस्टिट्यूट ऑन ड्रग एब्यूज अ
इंट्रा म्यूरल रिसर्च प्रोग्राम ओके आरपी
ओके ये किसी और गवर्नमेंट की वेबसाइट है
गवर्नमेंट ऑफ इंडिया की तो नहीं है कोई और
गवर्नमेंट इंडिया की है क्या
यार आई डोंट नो ठीक है यहां पे एक और
वेबसाइट है चलिए इसको भी ओपन कर लेते हैं
हिमालयन ग्लेशियर करके है बहुत सारी
वेबसाइट्स आपको मिल जाएंगी ठीक है इसके
रिजल्ट में तो यू कैन सी एनी ऑफ द वेबसाइट
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है चलिए तो अब आते हैं
यहां पे नाउ वी आर गोइंग टू सी हियर अब
यहां पे जब आएंगे ना तो इन वेबसाइट्स को
जब यहां पे ओपन करेंगे तो यू विल सी कि ये
मोरा ब्यूट मोरा ब्यूट मोब 2ab 2.com तो
यहां पे ये कुछ लिस्टेड है तो यहां पे
आपको आरएसडी वर्जन यहां पे देखने को मिल
रही है ठीक है उसके बाद यहां पे वपस आ रहा
है wordpress.org यहां पे वेबसाइट की नाम
आ रही है एंड यहां पे कुछ एंटिटीज आ रही
है जैसे कि मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं जैसे
कि वर्डप्रेस ठीक है तो ब्लॉग आईडी
प्रेफर्ड एपीआई लिंक एंड यहां पे दिया हुआ
है एपीआई लिंक यानी कि एक्सएमएलआरपीसी ड
पीएपी वाली जो
आपकी यूआरएल है वो दी हुई है चलिए अब इस
यूआरएल को हम यहां से ओपन
करेंगे वी विल ओपन दिस
यूआरएल चलिए ओपन कर रहे
हैं ओपन करते ही क्या आ रहा है xmlrpc.php
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको मिल है देख रहे हो
कितना कितना ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन मिल रहा है
इस पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट का अब इसमें मुझे
कुछ फिल्टर आउट करना है मैं यहां पे स्लैड
प एंड स् वर्जन टू स् यूजर्स को फिल्टर
करता हूं इस ये यूआरएल पे अगर यूजर्स
फिल्टर करके हम ट्राई कर सकते हैं टू गेट
सम डिटेल्स तो यहां पे क्या आ रहा है सॉरी
यू आर नॉट अलाउड टू द टू लिस्ट यूजर्स तो
यहां पे ये प्रोटेक्टेड है यहां पे ये
प्रोटेक्टेड है यू कैन नॉट सी द यूजर्स
लिस्ट तो चलिए ये तो हमने देख लिया कि
भैया यहां पे ये प्रोटेक्टेड है आप यूजर्स
लिस्ट तो नहीं देख सकते हो अच्छी बात है
ये दिस इज अ गुड थिंग चलिए तो इस टारगेट
को हम फिलहाल के लिए हटा देते हैं हमारे
किसी का काम नहीं है अब चलिए अब यहां पे
है ये कोई गवर्नमेंट वेबसाइट है चलिए इनका
भी डब्ल्यूपी जसन फाइल है इसको हम यहां
पे कर लेते हैं यहां पे ओपन देन अगेन
डब्ल्यूपी वर्जन टू एंड यहां पे यूजर्स
ठीक है यहां पे ओपन करके एक्सेस करते हैं
हां जी इसमें हम एक्सेस कर पा रहे हैं नाउ
वी कैन एक्सेस इट अब यहां पे आप देखोगे ना
एक्सेस करके तो यहां पे देखो ये जेसन
फॉर्मेट में यहां पे आ रहा है यहां पे
आईडी टू यहां पे है नेम यहां पे एरन रसेल
ठीक है ये क्या है स्लग जो है एर एरस नहीं
ए आर रसल ए आर रसल है ठीक है एरन रसल को ए
ए रसल ए रसल बोलो ए रसल है यहां पे यहां
पे लॉरेन ब्रिक ठीक है यहां पे एल ब्रिक
यहां पे आ रहा है यहां पे एन आईडीए आईआर
पी यहां पे आ रहा है क्या आ रहा है एस यू
वर्डप्रेस देखो अब ये एस यू वर्डप्रेस से
क्या समझ में आ रहा है तुम्हें यहां पे एक
यूजर यहां पे एक अ आईडी मिली है मुझे एस
यू वर्डप्रेस इससे तुम इससे समझ जाएगा जो
समझने वाला होगा एस यू वर्डप्रेस का मतलब
क्या लग रहा है तुम्हें बताओ जल्दी जल्दी
बताओ व्हाट यू अंडरस्टैंडिंग व्हाट यू
गेटिंग बाय एस यू वर्डप्रेस इस यूजर नेम
से तुम्हें क्या समझ में आ रहा है इस नाम
से एयू वर्डप्रेस
बताइए बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया सुपर यूजर
वर्डप्रेस हां तो यह हो सकता है यह हो
सकता है यह हमारा जो पर्टिकुलर एस
वर्डप्रेस है यह एक सुपर एडमिन या एडमिन
है जो पर्टिकुलर इस जगह पे हमें एक रिजल्ट
मिला है इसमें ठीक है यहां पे मैक मार्क
ले करके यहां पे आ रहा है कोई यूजर आ रहा
है इस तरीके से करके हमें यूजर्स मिले हैं
अब रॉ डाटा पे जाओगे तुम रॉ डेटा देखोगे
तो रॉ डेटा यहां पे तुम्हें मिल जाएगी
यहां पे तो बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन यहां
मिलेगी तुम इसको जूम इन करोगे तो तुम अपना
जूम इन करके यहां पे देख सकते हो देयर कि
यहां पे आईडी टू है नेम एरन रसल है यूआरएल
यहां पे कुछ है एंड यहां पे लिंक दी हुई
है एंड स्लग जो है ए रसल यहां पे दिया हुआ
है तो वी आर गेटिंग सम काइंड ऑफ़ व्हाट सम
काइंड ऑफ़ यूजर्स तो हमें यूजर्स मिल रहे
हैं चलिए यह यूजर्स मिल रहे हैं अच्छी बात
है दैट इज़ अ वेरी गुड थिंग कि वी आर
गेटिंग यूजर्स एंड ऑन व्हिच ऑन दिस
पर्टिकुलर डोमेन सॉरी ऑन दिस पर्टिकुलर
डोमेन वी आर गेटिंग द यूजर्स अब इसको ना
हम ल्यप स्कैन से भी सर्च कर सकते हैं यह
बात आपको पता होना चाहिए कि हम यूज़र
एन्यूमरेशन वी कैन डू विद डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन
आल्सो डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन टूल से आप कर सकते
हो इसके लिए सिंपल आपको डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन
ओपन करना है और उस पे परफॉर्म करना है तो
आप मैच अप कर सकते हो कि भैया अच्छा ये और
इससे मैच कर रहा है क्या कर रहा है यू कैन
मैच अप तो पहले मैं एक बार काली भी ओपन
करके रख देता हूं एंड देन वी विल ट्राई ऑन
दैट आल्सो ठीक है तो काली कोपन जाने दीजिए
तब तक हम इधर आ जाते हैं
चलिए चलिए तो इसमें हमारा ये लिस्ट हो रहा
है तो ये चलिए एक वेबसाइट है cor.com तो
cor.com पे डप जसन हम इसको ओपन करके देखते
हैं cor.com लेट्स सी स्ड
pv2 स् यूजर्स ठीक है लेट्स से इट्स एक्स
लाइक
एक्सेसिबल और नॉट नहीं है एक्सेसिबल नहीं
है इसको बटा देते हैं कोई बात नहीं नाउ
केटी ए kct.ac.in यह कोई कॉलेज या कुछ
होगा एजुकेशनल इंस्टिट्यूट
होगी इसका भी ओपन कर लेते हैं
स्ल डब्लू प स्ल v2 स् यूजर्स ठीक है तो
देखते हैं य
पे या तो यह भी एक्सेसिबल है यू कैन सी य
दिस इज आल्सो एक्सेसिबल तो यहां पे अनुराग
एडमिन चलो ये एक मिला हमें अनुराग एडमिन
तो भैया यह तो एडमिन का हमें मिल गया यूजर
नेम अनुराग एडमिन है यह यूजर नेम होगा 110
पर है और भी यहां पे
है अनुराग एडमिन है चलो एक ही बंदा आई
थिंक हां चंद्रशेखर एक चंद्रशेखर भी मिला
है भैया ऑथर है आपके चंद्रशेखर यहां पे आप
जाओगे यहां पे ओपन लिंक करो इसके प्रोफाइल
आ जाएगी यहां पे तो ऑथर में आपको आ रहा है
अनुराग एडमिन एंड यहां पे यू कैन सी यू
कैन फाइंड हियर ग्रेट एंड यहां पे हमारे
भैया ये अनुराग एडमिन यही है यही अनुराग
एडमिन ही है ठीक है तो वी आर गेटिंग द
रिजल्ट्स हियर तो यहां पे मोरा बीटर ये तो
नहीं था इसमें नहीं आ रहा था बट इसमें
हमें एक्सएमएल आरपीसी तो इनेबल्ड है बट
यूजर लिस्टिंग इनेबल नहीं है तो हम कोई
बात नहीं हम उसको देखेंगे कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं उसको वी विल सी इट ठीक है तो तीन
वेबसाइट्स हमारे पास आ चुकी हैं एंड एक
पहले का हमारा टारगेट था ही फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट
करके ये आपको पता होगा फूट forest.in फिर
डब्ल्यूपी हाई अ डब्ल्यूपी
आईन जसन स्ड प स् v2 स्
यूजर्स एंड यह भी लीक कर रहा था इसका भी
मैंने देखा हुआ था सो हियर यू विल सी कि
फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट आयन यह एक यूजर है आपका
फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट आयन करके ठीक है एंड देर आर
मल्टीपल यूजर्स आल्सो सो एक यह वाली यूजर
है ठीक है स्टिकी सेन करके आई थिंक ये भी
ऑथर ही है एंड इस नाम से आई थिंक मे बी
इनका वो भी होगा डेटाबेस शायद मे बी तो
यहां पे ये ऑथर भी आ रहा है यहां पे ठीक
है तो यहां पे लिस्टिंग इनेबल्ड है चलिए
अब यहां पे क्या करते हैं ना व्हाट वी आर
गोइंग टू डू अब हम देखते हैं इसको कि हम
किस तरीके से वी कैन एक्सप्लोइट इट हाउ वी
कैन एक्सप्लोइट इट ठीक है तो यहां पे आप
जब इस गिट हब के इस पर्टिकुलर रेपो पे
आइएगा तो यहां पे अलग-अलग चीजें दी हैं दी
गई है अलग-अलग तरीके एक्सप्लोइट करने के
लिए तो यहां पे एक्सएमए की कोडिंग की
जरूरत पड़ेगी अब ये कोडिंग आपको समझ में
नहीं आएगा जब तक आप एक्सएमए नहीं जानते
हैं बट टेंपररी क्या करेंगे हम टेंपररी
जरूरी नहीं है कि एक्सएमएल पढ़ के आपको ये
फिर करना है टेंपररी समझने की कोशिश
करेंगे बस
दैट्ची यही है एक जब तुम पेन टेस्टिंग
करते हो ना इसका एक बहुत अच्छा ब्यूटी
क्या है ना इसका कि तुम्हें किसी लैंग्वेज
की जरूरत नहीं है सच में सच बता रहा हूं
मैं बट तुम हंट करते टाइम ना जब तुम हंट
कर रहे हो उसी टाइम उस लैंग्वेज को सीख लो
उतना सीखो जितना तुम्हें जरूरत है और
धीरे-धीरे धीरे-धीरे प्रैक्टिस करते जाओगे
ऑटोमेटिक तुम एडवांस होते चले जाओगे इसमें
तुम्हें जावास्क्रिप्ट पूरी नहीं सीखनी ना
नहीं सीखनी तुम्हें जैसे-जैसे नॉलेज जैसे
अ इवेंट हैंडलर का यूज करना सीख लिया कौन
से टैक्स को कहां पर किस तरीके से उसका
मतलब क्या होता है किस तरीके से परफॉर्म
करी है वो सीख लिया ऑब्जेक्ट सीख लिया तो
तुम्हें धीरे-धीरे नॉलेज होती चली जाएगी
ऐसा नहीं कि अ अब जावास्क्रिप्ट भाई आ गया
तो अब पकड़ के जावास्क्रिप्ट मतलब नहीं छ
महीने तो नहीं लगेगा तीन महीने जावा
स्क्रिप्ट सीखने में लगा दिया दो महीने
जावा स्क्रिप्ट सीखने में लगा दिया ना ऐसा
नहीं करना है ठीक है टाइम वेस्ट नहीं
करना तो चलिए अब यहां पे पोस्ट मेथड में
कैसे इसको यूज करना है तो सिंपली आपको
एक्सएमएल की इस तरह की कोड डालनी है एंड
आपका मेथड लिस्ट करना है
दैट्ची ओपन करूंगा ठीक है चलिए बॉब शूट
ओपन करने से पहले मैं काली को लॉग इन कर
लेता
हूं हां और यहां पे यूजर जो लिस्टिंग हो
रही थी उसको काली में भी देख लेते एक बार
ताकि आपको क्लियर हो
जाए जैसे यह यूजर लिस्ट हो रहा था
kct.ac.in ये हमारा टारगेट है मान लो
केसीटी
सो व्हाट वी विल डू वी विल यूज डब्ल्यूपी
स्कन है ना तो डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन यूज करते
हैं एंड हान हाइफ य आरएल एंड उसके बाद
यहां पे देते हैं
kct.ac.in
यही हमारा kct.ac.in ठीक है उसके बाद
एन्यूमरेशन के लिए अब तुम्हें जब समझ में
ना आए कुछ भी ना आए तो यहां पे एंड अ क्या
करेंगे डब्लू प स्कन हान h करेंगे एंड यू
विल फाइंड द हेल्प फाइल ओके तो जब तुम
हेल्प फाइल फाइंड करोगे तो यहां पे हान ई
आ रहा है इनमेट ऑप्शन के लिए एंड हाइन ई
के बाद इनमेट के बाद यू यूज करना आपको
यूजर्स के लिए जो भी यूजर्स को आप इनमेट
करना है तो मैं हान ई यूज करता हूं एंड
देन आई एम गोइंग टू डू हाइन ई के बाद यू
ठीक है क्या बोल रहे हो अरे मैं चैट पर
ध्यान नहीं दे रहा था भाई सर आपका मैंने
कोर्स लिया है एथिकल हैकिंग का लेकिन मैं
सीए सर्टिफाइड हूं बट मेरे को और नॉलेज
चाहिए एंड तो मेरे क्वेश्चन है कि बग
बाउंट वाला आपका कोर्स करके पूरा या पहले
एथिकल हैकिंग वाली कर लो जब वीपीटी की
आएगी तो उसमें आ जाना वीपीटी ट्रेनिंग जो
होने वाली है वह बहुत अलग लेवल पर होने
वाली है गाइस दैट इज अ डिफरेंट वो
इंडस्ट्री ट्रेनिंग है इंडस्ट्रियल जो
ट्रेनिंग होती है ना इंडस्ट्री में
एक्चुअल कंपनी में जैसे अब तुम मैं आपको
एक सिंपल सा एग्जांपल देता हूं मान लो तुम
जॉब के लिए जा रहे हो जॉब के लिए ट्राई कर
रहे हो ठीक है और जॉब
असिस्टेंसिया हैं उसको हम बोल रहे हैं कि
जॉब ओरिएंटेड है इसके पीछे रीजन है इसलिए
बोल रहे हैं तो ये ट्रेनिंग मान लो तुम
किसी कंपनी में गया अप्लाई किया तुमने
विपो में एसील में डेल वाइट में केपीएमजी
में samsung-ro
तुम जब अगर किसी जगह जॉब करने जा रहे हो
तुम्हें किसी तरह की ट्रेनिंग की जरूरत
नहीं पड़ेगी एंड यू विल बी नोइंग एवरीथिंग
पहले से पता होगा तुम्हें तो तुम ऐसे
इंटरव्यूज को ना ऐसे हवा में उड़ा दोगे और
इस पर्टिकुलर वीपीटी ट्रेनिंग में हम मॉक
इंटरव्यूज राउंड रखने वाले हैं एक रिव्यूज
रिज्यूमे रिव्यूज एंड रिज्यूमे क्रिएशन
एंड कैसे आपको अपना पोर्टफोलियो बना के और
आपको हम अप्लाई करवाएंगे कंपनीज में
पर्टिकुलर यहां अप्लाई करो यहां अप्लाई
करो और इंटरव्यू कैसे क्लियर करना है वो
भी बताए और इंटरव्यू में क्या-क्या पूछे
जाते एक्चुअल में जो इंडस्ट्रियल इंटरव्यू
में पूछा जाता है जो कंपनी में वो वाला
ऐसा नहीं कि ये बच्चों वाला कि भैया
नॉर्मल सा कोई एक एंट्री लेवल जॉब ना
उसमें नहीं तो एक्चुअल में क्या इंटरव्यू
में सिक्योरिटी डोमेन पूछा जाता है उस
तरीके का प्रिपरेशन असिस्टेंट सब कुछ
देंगे हम किसी भी ट्रेनिंग में अपने नहीं
बोलते हैं कि आपको हम जॉब दिला देंगे
लेकिन इस ट्रेनिंग में हम बोल रहे हैं कि
दिस ट्रेनिंग विल बी जॉब
ओरिएंटेड और इस ट्रेनिंग से बंदे निकलेंगे
जिनका जॉब हो जाएगा मैं गारंटी आपको देता
हूं हम पहले नहीं बोलेंगे कुछ भी भी
क्योंकि बाद में क्या बोलते हैं लोग उसको
गलत फॉल्स क्लेम में डाल देते हैं तो हम
उसी तरीके का यह ट्रेनिंग लेकर आ रहे हैं
बस ट्स इट अभी ज्यादा डिटेल में आएगी तो
पता चल
जाएगा 30 के प्राइस तो नहीं होगा प्राइस
30 के नहीं होगा याद रखो प्राइस का जो
प्राइस का जो तुम देखो प्राइसिंग जो है
ना वह इसका थोड़ा सा ज्यादा हमें करना पड़
रहा है इसका रीजन है ज्यादा का रीजन है
मैं आपको उसका भी प्रॉपर रीजन बता देता
हूं कोर्स की ड्यूरेशन चार से 6 महीने
होगी वीकेंड फोर टू सिक्स मंथ्स इसमें
आपका क्या है इंटर्नशिप इंक्लूडेड है आपका
इसमें पूरी फुल प्रैक्टिकल ट्रेनिंग
इंक्लूडेड है एकदम से जॉब ओरिएंटेड वाली
ट्रेनिंग इंक्लूडेड है मॉक इंटरव्यूज
इंक्लूडेड है हर एक चीज इंक्लूडेड है तो
इसकी ट्रेनिंग थोड़ी सी फी जो है थोड़ी सी
आई होगी बट डीसीएसपी के ट्रेनिंग से जो फी
होती है उससे कम होगी डीसीएसपी की
ट्रेनिंग फी है ₹2000000 अगर आपको पता हो
तो उस से कम होगी बस इतना जान जाओ अब
अंदाजा लगा लेना ठीक
है चलिए तो यहां पर हम हान हान य करते हैं
यूजर न्यूमरेशन की हम कोशिश करते हैं केड
ए आ में एंड देन हम एंटर करते हैं नाउ
लेट्स सी व्ट इज हैपनिंग कुछ हमें रिजल्ट
मिलता है इस पे या नहीं मिलता है ठीक है
चलिए तो यहां पर आईपी वर्जन 6 यहां प हम
मिल रहा है केसीटी एड की हिंदी में होगी
ट्रेनिंग भाई ऑनलाइन होगी कंप्लीट ऑनलाइन
हिंदी
चलिए ठीक है वी आर गेटिंग सम
रिजल्ट्स वी आर गेटिंग सम
रिजल्ट्स ओके अब यहां पे आ रहा है नमरे इि
यूजर्स वाया पैसिव एंड अग्रेसिव मेथड ठीक
है पैसिव एंड अग्रेसिव मेथड के थ्रू ये
नरेट कर रहा है आई एम फ्रॉम बांग्लादेश
ओके ब्रदर आई एम फ्रॉम
इंडिया चलिए यह यहां पे आ रहा है ब्रूट
फोर्स कर रहा है ब्रूट फोर्सिंग ऑथर
आईडी एंड
कुछ नहीं मिला क्या हां मिला मिला इसको
यहां पर रिजल्ट मिला क्या बात है या इट
कैन बी पेड इन इंस्टॉलमेंट्स इन थ्री
इंस्टॉलमेंट्स
या या सो हियर वी फाउंड सम यूजर्स एक तो
अनुराग एडमिन मिला एक यही अनुराग एडमिन
मिला एक चंद्रशेखर मिला चलिए अच्छी बात है
चंद्रशेखर ठीक है अच्छी बात है एक विमल
मिला विमल भी हमें मिला है भैया एक विमल
देखो तो इस कई बार देखो हमेशा एक तरीका
अपना हमेशा एक तरीका आजमाना मैनुअल और
ऑटोमेटेड मेथड दोनों का कॉमिनेशन यूज करना
है आपको बग बाउंट के टाइम पे याद रखिएगा
मैनुअल भी करना है ऑटोमेशन भी करनी है कई
बार कुछ चीजें आप मैनुअल में नहीं पकड़
सकते आपको शायद मिस कर जाए ना मिले आप मिस
कर जाए लेकिन वो ऑटोमेटेड में आपको मिल
जाएगा बहुत इजली सामने दिख जाएगा कुछ
चीजें ऑटोमेटेड टूल्स आपको फाइंड करके
नहीं दे सकती जो मैनुअली आप फाइंड कर लोगे
तो आपको दोनों कंबाइन करके चलना है यू विल
गेट द बेट बेटर रिजल्ट ठीक है तो यहां पर
देख सकते हो आपको आपको यहां पर भी यूजर्स
की लिस्ट यहां प यूजर नेम वगैरह मिल चुकी
है आपको बढ़िया है बढ़िया है कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है सेम आप टारगेट जो है चेंज करके एक
हमारा दूसरा जो टारगेट
था यह टारगेट
था सो आवर सेकंड टारगेट इज दिस सो लेट्स
प्रोवाइड दिस टारगेट एस
इनपुट तो हम ये टारगेट दे देते एक बार
अ ठीक है लेट्स
सी डीसी जीएसपी करो कोई बात नहीं डीसी
जेएसपी करो डी डीसी जेएसपी इज अ डिफरेंट
थिंग डीसी जेएसपी अलग है वो सिर्फ एथिकल
हैकिंग का है वो और कुछ नहीं है डीसी
जेएसपी इज जस्ट एथिकल हैकिंग का पूरा
एथिकल हैकिंग आपको उसमें पूरी जो एथिकल
हैकिंग के जनरल टॉपिक्स है ना वो आपको
सिखाया जाता है डीसीजीए पी में एंड वीपीटी
जो है यह लेबिलिटी असेसमेंट एंड
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के ऊपर फोकस्ड है
दोनों में बहुत डिफरेंस है
यार ठीक है तो यहां देखो एक्सएमएल आरपीसी
सीम्स टू बी इनेबल्ड ब्रूट फोर्सिंग यहां
पर चल रही है भैया अच्छी बात है 100%
कॉन्फिडेंस में है
यह लेटस
[संगीत]
सी सर आपकी कंपनी में इंटर्नशिप
अपॉर्चुनिटी भी मिलेगी तो उसको अप्लाई
कैसे करना है मेरी भी एक जगह इंटर्नशिप चल
रही है ओसिट इन्वेस्टिगेटर बढ़िया है
हमारी जब इंटर्नशिप अपॉर्चुनिटी आएगी तो
आपको पता चल जाएगा हमारी पहली जो प्योर
इंटर्नशिप अपॉर्चुनिटी अभी जो आने वाली है
वैसे हम डीसीएसपी में भी इंटर्नशिप कराते
हैं प्रोजेक्ट के थ्रू प्रोजेक्ट
इंटर्नशिप होती है वो लेकिन अभी जो आ रही
है वीपीटी वाली ट्रेनिंग ये एक
इंडस्ट्रियल प्रोजेक्ट इंटर्नशिप होगी
मतलब कि इसमें आपको एक्चुअल में जो
इंटर्नशिप का आपको मजा आने वाला है ना वो
मजा आपको आएगा इस पर्टिकुलर अपकमिंग
वीपीटी ट्रेनिंग में तो उसके लिए वेट
कीजिए आने दीजिए
फिंगर प्रिंटिंग द वर्जन जल्दी हो जाओ भाई
क्या इतना टाइम लगा रहे हो इतना टाइम लगता
है
क्या देखो टटी में क्या-क्या इंक्लूडेड है
कि भैया डब्ल्यूपी इंक्लूड्स नहीं करना है
डब्ल्यूपी लॉगइन नहीं करना है डब्ल्यूपी
रजिस्टर और पीएपी नहीं करना है इंक्लूड
इमेजेस इंक्लूड जेएस यह सब यहां पे हटाया
हुआ है ठीक है अच्छी
बात पहले तो यार
अ स्पैम मत करो
भाई हां हां हां करेक्ट करेक्ट 702 टोटल
702 में से फोर समथिंग हो चुके हैं थोड़े
और अभी बचे हुए हैं हो रहे हैं वो लेट्स
लेट्स
वेट हो जाएगा जल्दी हो जाएगा तुम लोग में
से स्टॉक मार्केट में इन्वेस्ट कौन करता
है स्विंग मतलब स्विंग ट्रेडिंग नॉट इन
ऑप्शंस ऑप्शंस की बात नहीं कर रहा मैं
नॉर्मल स्टॉक मार्केट में स्विंग ट्रेडिंग
स्टॉक्स की या स्कल्पिन बोल लो जो भी
बोललो माइक कौन है माइक है रोड एंटी
यूएसबी एंटी मिनी यूएसबी रोड एंटी मिनी
यूएसबी छोटा सा माइक है 10000 के आसपास का
आ जाएगा आपको
इंट्राडे में वाह क्या बात है इंट्राडे
वाले भी
हैं नहीं नहीं यार स्टॉक मार्केट के ऊपर
कोर्स सस नहीं ला रहा मैं स्टॉक मार्केट
के ऊपर कोई कोर्स नहीं
आएगा यह मैंने ऐसे पूछा हाउ टू स्टार्ट
स्टार्टअप इन साइबर सिक्योरिटी चलो वीडियो
बना दूंगा वैसे कैसे बता दूं अभी यहां पर
छोटा टॉपिक तो है नहीं यार
क्या परेशान हो गया
भाई तो सर मेरे को बेसिक आता है तो बग
बाउंट करू आईटी से हां करो टेक एक्स बग
बांटी करो अगर बेसिक आता है तो करो
बिल्कुल
करो अब देखो यहां पर फिंगर प्रिंटिंग हुई
है यहां पर नाउ ब्रूट फोर्सिंग हो रही ऑथर
के लिए तो यह जल्दी हो
जाएगा ठीक
है तो यहां पर यूज कर रहे हैं स्टूडियो
प्रेस करके कोई थीम यूज कर रहे जेनेसिस
अच्छा जेनेसिस अप्लाई किया ठीक
है बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
यहां पर एक ऑथर था आया हुआ था मैनुअल में
देखते हैं कि ऑटोमेटेड में यह खोज पाता है
कि
नहीं लेट्स सी
सर आपके सिस्टम की स्पेक्स क्या है मैं
सिस्टम की स्पेक्स बहुत ज्यादा अच्छी तो
नहीं है ठीक है यहां पर इसने खोज के निकाल
लिया भाई पहला एक है नीडा आईआरपी जो भी है
हटाओ ए रसल जो हमने खोजा हुआ था वो आया
यहां पे ठीक
है एल ब्रिक आया यहां पे एस यू वर्डप्रेस
आया ठीक है भाई एस यू वर्डप्रेस समझे तो
एस यू वर्डप्रेस आ चुका है क्या बात है
यहां पे मार्क फेले यहां पर आ गया तो सारे
यहां पर खोज के यहां प आ जा रहे हैं हमारे
पास वी आर गेटिंग ठीक है तो ये अच्छी बात
है चलिए अब क्या करना है ना अब हम
एक्सएमएल आरपीसी को एक्सप्लोइट करने की
कोशिश करेंगे वी विल बी ट्राइम टू
एक्सप्लोइट एक्सएमएल
आरपीसी तो एक्सएमएल आरपीसी कैसे
एक्सप्लोइट होगी जैसे मान लो ये आईआरपी ये
वाली वेबसाइट है xmlrpc.php इसको ओपन करने
की कोशिश करोगे तो यहां पे ये चीज लिखी
आएगी कि एक्सएमएलआरपीसी एक्सेप्ट पोस्ट
रिक्वेस्ट ओनली मतलब यहां पे हम
एक्सप्लोइट कर सकते हैं वी कैन ट्राई इट
आउट ठीक है तो हम यहां पे xmlrpc.php यहां
पे लिख देते सॉरी यह तो फिर यही ओपन हो
जाएगा तो ओनली पीएचपी यह वाली ओपन कर लेते
हैं ठीक है यह भी यहां पे चलो यहां पे यह
भी है एंड यहां पे एक्सएमएल आरपीसी ड
पीएपी एंड इसमें भी ओपन है तो ये यहां पे
ये एरर आ रही है इसका मतलब ये नहीं कि
एक्सएमएल आरपीसी इनेबल नहीं है इसका मतलब
है एक्सएमएल आरपीसी इनेबल्ड है डिसेबल्ड
होता ना तो पता है क्या लिखता डिसेबल्ड
होता है डिसेबल्ड होता तो एक्स लिखता
xmlrpc.php
अगर एक्सल आरपीसी डिसेबल्ड है तो ऐसा आ
जाता सीधा कि यह भाई डिसेबल्ड है जैसे
हमारा डिक्स प डिसेबल्ड है ठीक है तो अभी
हम क्या करते हैं हमें बहुत सारी
वेबसाइट्स मिल चुकी हैं ऑलरेडी तो हम किसी
एक वेबसाइट पर ट्राई करते हैं जैसे
kct.ac.in यहां प हम ट्राई कर लेते हैं
ठीक है इसम भी वी कैन ट्राई व्हाट एवर तो
अब हमें क्या करना है इस इसके इसके इसका
जो रिक्वेस्ट है इस पेज को xmlrpc.php
इसको इंटरसेप्ट करना है अपने बब सूट से
ठीक है तो चलिए हम बब शूट को ओपन कर लेते
हैं लेट्स स्टार्ट द बब शूट
लेट्स
स्टार्ट हेलो सर आई एम विकाश फ्रॉम नेपाल
आई वांट टू लर्न एथिकल हैकिंग विथ यू
व्हाट विल बी द प्रोसीजर टू एडमिट आई हैड
टेक्स्ट यू ऑन
whatsapp's एंड रिस्पांस ओके विकाश यू विल
गेट द
रिस्पांस सर आई एम न्यू टू साइबर
सिक्योरिटी
अ जस्ट पास्ट 12थ प्लीज हेल्प मी टू
स्टार्ट 12थ अभी 12थ में हो तो अभी तो 12थ
का पे भी ध्यान देना बाकी
बहुत सारी ऑनलाइन रिसोर्सेस है उससे सीखते
रहो हमारी
डीजे अवी क्या बात है डीजे अवी कहां कहां
गायब कहां हो कहां गायब हो भाई चलिए तो
यहां पे अब हम क्या कर लेते हैं यहां पे
मैं बॉब शूट वाली प्रॉक्सी इनेबल कर देता
हूं एंड केसीटी ए आ को हम इंटरसेप्ट कर
लेते हैं इंटरसेप्ट ऑन करते हैं यहां पे
एंड यहां पे इसको रीलोड करते हैं इस पेज
को जैसे ही रीलोड करेंगे हमारे बब शूट में
ये इंटरसेप्ट हो जाएगा यहां पे हम राइट
क्लिक करके इसको सेंड टू रिपीटर पे क्लिक
कर देंगे सेंड टू रिपीटर करके इंटरसेप्ट
को ऑफ कर देंगे ठीक है दैट्ची
ऊपर तो हम रिपीटर के ऊपर आ चुके हैं भैया
वी आर ऑन द रिपीटर राइट नाउ जब हम रिपीटर
प आ गए हम यहां पर गो प क्लिक करेंगे ना
तो यहां पे देखो क्या
आएगा 405 मेथड नॉट अलाउड मतलब यहां पे आ
रहा है कि मेथड अलाउड नहीं है ठीक है भैया
बस अब यहां पे ऑप्शंस मान लो हम ऑप्शंस
लगा देते हैं यहां पर हम गो प क्लिक करते
हैं ऑप्शन लगाया हमने गो प क्लिक गो प
क्लिक किया नहीं यहां ऑप्शन यहां पर किया
गो प क्लिक किया
अब देखो यहां पे ऑप्शन यहां पे हमने किया
तो यहां पे आ रहा है कि व्ट व्हाट इट इज
कमिंग 400 बैड रिक्वेस्ट यहां पे इसको ये
कंडक्ट नहीं कर रहा है बट हम अगर यहां पे
मैं देखना चाह रहा था बट य यहां पे गेट जो
हमारा गेट रिक्वेस्ट था उसको हम करते हैं
तो यहां पे क्या आ रहा है 405 मेथड नॉट
अलाउड मतलब ये मेथड भैया हमारा अलाउड नहीं
है तो चलिए अच्छी बात है अलाउड नहीं है अब
हम क्या करेंगे ना इसका मेथड चेंज कर
देंगे राइट क्लिक करेंगे एंड चेंज
रिक्वेस्ट मेथड तो गेट से पोस्ट कर देंगे
अब ये कहां आ गया पोस्ट में आ गया पोस्ट
में आ गया अब हम इसको गो पे क्लिक करेंगे
जब हम गो पर क्लिक करेंगे तो अब यहां पर
200 ओके आ रहा है मतलब अब वी कैन एक्सेस द
दिस पर्टिकुलर पेज तो हम एक्सेस कर पा रहे
हैं क्योंकि यह एक एक्सएमएल आरपीसी पेज है
जो कि पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट एक्सेप्ट करती है
तो हमने रिक्वेस्ट को पोस्ट कर दिया तो वी
कैन नाउ एक्सेस इट अब क्या करते हैं अब हम
एक्सएमएल की भाषा थोड़ा पढ़ते हैं समझते
हैं उसको हमारे पास एक्सएल की एक भाषा है
यह
वाली यह वाली भाषा
है एक्सएल की यहां मैंने पेस्ट किया अब इस
भाषा को थोड़ा समझते हैं भाषा में क्या है
यहां पर एक्सएमएल की सिंपल सी एक सिंटेक्स
दी हुई है जैसे आपकी अलग-अलग कोडिंग में
जैसे बैश का हो गया आपका जैसे कि पीएचपी
का हो गया अलग-अलग आपके एचटीएमएल का हो
गया एचटीएमएल वगैरह होता है सब कुछ है तो
यह दिया हुआ है इसको आप यूज ना भी करो
चलेगा कोई बात नहीं आपकी मर्जी है और यहां
पर लिखा हुआ है यहां पर हम रहने देते हैं
ठीक है चलिए अब यहां पर आ रहा है एक मेथड
कॉल इसका मतलब होता है यह टैग है मेथड कॉल
एक मेथड कॉल का टैग होता है जो मेथड्स को
मेंशन करने के लिए यूज़ किया जाता है जो
एक्सएमए के अंदर हम मेथड्स को यूज करते
हैं अब मेथड के अलग-अलग नाम है एक्सएमए के
अंदर में जैसे कि एक मेथड नेम क्या है सिम
डॉट लिस्ट मेथड्स ये एक नाम है इससे बाकी
जितने भी मेथड्स हैं जो इस पर्टिकुलर
वेबसाइट पे हम एक्सेस कर सकते हैं लिस्ट
कर सकते हैं हम इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हैं उस
वेबसाइट से वो सारे लिस्ट कर देगा उसके
बाद मेथड नेम आपका टैग क्लोज हो गया फिर
उसके बाद आ जाता है पैरामीटर्स यानी कि
हमें पैरामीटर भी देने हैं अब ये पैरामीटर
तब आएंगे यू जब हम दूसरे कोई मेथड यूज
करेंगे जिसमें पैरामीटर की नीड है जैसे हम
ब्रूट फोर्स करेंगे हम ब्रूट फोर्स भी
करके देखेंगे कैसे ब्रूट फोर्स करते हैं
वो भी देखेंगे ठीक है उसके बाद हम और भी
एक चीज है वो भी देखेंगे ठीक है और उसके
बाद मेथड कॉल को हमने बंद कर दिया सेम
आपका जैसे एचटीएमएल है ना वैसे ही है
एचटीएमएल क्या है हाइपर टेक्स्ट एचटीएमएल
क्या है हाइपर टेक्स्ट मार्कअप लैंग्वेज
ठीक है राइट हाइपर टेक्स्ट और ये क्या
एक्सटेंसिबल मार्कअप लैंग्वेज बस यही है
है मार्कअप लैंग्वेज ही दोनों तो यहां पे
अब हमने इसको कॉपी किया है हम इसको यहां प
सिंपल बब शूट के अंदर में यहां पे बॉडी
में यहां पे पेस्ट कर देंगे हमने बॉडी में
पेस्ट किया यहां पे अब हम यहां प गो प
क्लिक करेंगे एंड वी विल सी व्हाट इज द
रिस्पांस वी आर गेटिंग लेट्स गो क्लिक
गो ओके तो जैसे ही हमने गो प क्लिक किया
वी आर गेटिंग सम रिजल्ट्स वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग रिजल्ट्स एंड यहां पे
रिजल्ट्स देखो वर्जन 1.0 जो भी है यहां पे
एंड हमने जो लिस्ट मेथड किया
था कोर्स आएगा इसी मंथ के एंड में
अनाउंसमेंट आएगी लिस्ट मेथड किया था उसमें
हमें रिजल्ट्स मिल गए अब यह सारे मेथड्स
हैं जो हम यहां पर यूज कर सकते हैं इस
पर्टिकुलर वलन बिलिटी के कारण एक्सएमएल
आरपीसी के कारण यहां पे अब देखो क्या-क्या
कर सकते हैं देख लो यहां
पे डब्ल्यूपी न्यू ब्लॉग एडिट पोस्ट डिलीट
पोस्ट इवन वी कैन डिलीट अ पोस्ट समझ में आ
रहा है वी कैन डिलीट अ पोस्ट बट उसके लिए
हमें यूजर नेम पासवर्ड खोजनी पड़ेगी
कोई बात नहीं
ललित कोई बात
नहीं व्हाट आर यू डूइंग सर एक्सप्लेन
प्लीज नहीं लेट आओगे तो मैं एक्सप्लेन
नहीं कर पाऊंगा और प्रीवियस वीडियो नहीं
देखा है तो एक्सप्लेन नहीं कर पाऊंगा
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी उससे हमारा टाइम वेस्ट
होता है मनविंदर सिंह आपने या तो प्रीवियस
वीडियो नहीं देखी तभी आपको नहीं समझ में आ
रहा है जो इसका पार्ट वन था ठीक
है चलिए हेलो पल्लव हेलो
पल्लव चलिए एडिट टम डिलीट टम गेट टर्म
टैक्सनॉमी गेट यूजर्स देख रहे हो कोई बात
नहीं गेट यूजर्स तो आपको यूजर्स जो है
फाइंड करने हैं वो आ गया यहां पे गेट
प्रोफाइल ठीक है एडिट
पेज सॉरी डिलीट पोस्ट यह सारी डिलीट कमेंट
ठीक है भैया यहां पे डिलीट कमेंट यह ऑप्शन
यह सारे काम हम कर सकते हैं ब्लॉगर डट गेट
पोस्ट ब्लॉगर ड गेट यूजर ब्लॉगस ये सारी
बहुत सारी चीजें हैं यहां पे पिंग बैकड
पिंग मत मतलब हम पिंग बैक रिक्वेस्ट भी
यहां पे कहीं से मंगा सकते किसी पर्टिकुलर
टारगेट से मंगा सकते हैं अब इसका यूज करके
ना डॉस अटैक हो सकता है अब ये पिंग बैक
पिंग क्या है कि आपने किसी रिमोट टारगेट
से हम पिंग बैक मंगा रहे हैं मतलब रिमोट
टारगेट को बोल रहे हैं भैया इस पर्टिकुलर
वेबसाइट को इस पर्टिकुलर टारगेट को पिंग
करो अब करते जाओ करते जाओ करते जाओ बहुत
सारी प पिंग रिक्वेस्ट भेजो और उसको डाउन
कर दो तो ये भी हम कर सकते हैं और यहां पे
डेमो से हेलो समझ में आ रहा है डेमो से
हेलो व्हाट इज दिस डेमो से हेलो अब यह
इसलिए है बेसिकली सिंपल सा कि अगर बाय
चांस हमने यह यहां पे डाला डेमो से हेलो
और हमें रिजल्ट में हेलो प्रिंट होके आ
गया इसका मतलब वी आर इंटरेक्ट विद दैट
पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट समझ में आ रहा है मैंने
आपको बताया था यह एक एपीआई कॉल करता है
एंड वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट से इंटरेक्ट कराता
है थर्ड पार्टी को तो हम अभी मान लो थर्ड
पार्टी है हम अगर वेबसाइट से इंटरेक्ट कर
पा रहे हैं तो अगर हमने से हेलो किया तो
इधर से रिस्पांस में हेलो आना चाहिए अब यह
बताओ मुझे यह रिस्पांस कहां से आता है यह
बताइए मुझे आप लोग रिस्पांस कहां से आता
है मार्केटिंग टेक्स सर्विस मैं एक
वर्डप्रेस की वेबसाइट देता हूं हां दे दो
देखते हैं कौन सी वेबसाइट
है हां सर्वर से आता है यह रिस्पांस सर्वर
से आ रहा है यानी कि अगर सर्वर हमारे हेलो
का रिप्लाई करे इसका मतलब क्या हुआ अगर
सर्वर हम बोल रहे सर्वर को कि हेलो सर्वर
भी बोल रहा है हेलो इसका मतलब क्या
हुआ
बताइए बताइए इसका मतलब क्या
हुआ सर्वर इसका मतलब क्या
हुआ या सर्वर इसका मतलब यार सर्वर हमसे
बात कर रहा है वी कैन वी आर इंटरेक्ट विद
द सर्वर राइट तो व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू
हम यहां पे डेमो से हेलो वाला जो है इसको
कॉपी कर
लेते और यहां लिस्ट मेथड वाली जो हमारी यह
पर्टिकुलर वैल्यू है इसको हटा
के डेमो डॉट से हेलो करते हैं और यहां पर
गो पर क्लिक करते हैं ठीक है गो पर क्लिक
करते हैं एंड देन देखते हैं देखो जैसे
हमने गो पर क्लिक किया एंड हमने एंटर किया
मेथड रिस्पांस देख रहे हो य पे मेथड
रिस्पांस रिस्पांस में आ रहा है हेलो
सर्वर ने बोला क्या हेलो समझ में आ रहा है
से हेलो अब मान लो यहां पे से
डिफ्रॉक्ड से डिफ्रे गो पे क्लिक किया तो
यहां पे अब क्या आ रहा है फॉल्ट कोड ये आ
रहा है इस तरीके से कि यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट
मेथड डेमो से डिफर डज नॉट एजिस्ट अब इसलिए
बिकॉज ये जो से हेलो है ये इसका एक मेथड
है ठीक है ये से हेलो जो है ना ये एक मेथड
है तो आपको यही डालना होगा अगर ये यहां पे
रिजल्ट में आ रहा है कि भैया हां हेलो तो
इसका मतलब है कि हां हेलो कि हम इंटरेक्ट
कर रहे बट अगर कुछ और डालोगे तो नहीं
क्योंकि दिस इज अ पर्टिकुलर सिंटेक्स तो
सिंटेक्स को आप चेंज नहीं कर सकते जो
लैंग्वेज का है ठीक है तो यहां पे हमने से
हेलो किया यहां पे हेलो आया वी आर
इंटरेक्ट ंग विद दिस पर्टिकुलर डोमेन या
इस वेबसाइट से तो इसका मतलब है वी आर
बिल्कुल सही हम यहां पे एक्सएमएल वनबिल को
एक्सएमएल आरपीसी वनबिल को यहां पे हम
कंफर्म करते हैं वी आर कंफर्मिंग द
एक्सएमएल आरपीसी वनबिल दैट देर एजिस्ट एंड
वी आर इंटरेक्ट वी आर एबल टू इंटरेक्ट
पर्टिकुलर इंटरेक्ट हम कर पा रहे हैं इसको
एक और तरीके से देख सकते हैं पिंग बैक
वाली से हम क्या कर सकते हैं पिंग बैक से
तो चलिए हम इसको प्रीवियस रिक्वेस्ट प
लेके चलते
हैं अब यहां पे एक रिक्वेस्ट है यहां
देखो पिंग बैक डॉट पि ये वाली रिक्वेस्ट
है पिंग बैक डॉट पि तो हम यहां पे पिंग
बैक डॉट पिंग डाल देते हैं ठीक है हमने
डाल दिया अब जब तुम इसको गो करोगे ना देखो
क्या आ रहा है गो प क्लिक करो देखो क्या
रिजल्ट आ रहा है यहां पे गो पे जब हमने
क्लिक किया व्हाट आई एम गेटिंग फॉल्ट कोड
रो फॉल्ट स्ट्रिंग रो अब यहां पे इसलिए आ
रहा है ये क्योंकि इसको एक पैरामीटर चाहिए
इट नीड्स अ पैरामीटर कैसे पैरामीटर कैसे
चाहिए चलिए हम यहां पे यहां पे एक
रिक्वेस्ट है यहां पे इस तरीके से इसको
पैरामीटर जैसे हमने पैरामीटर को क्या किया
था पैरामीटर को पहले हमने क्या किया था
बंद कर दिया था राइट पैरामीटर को हमने
क्या किया था बंद किया था कुछ नहीं डाला
था यहां पे हमें एक पैरामीटर की वैल्यू
चाहिए जहां पे हम इस तरीके से मेंशन
करेंगे पर्टिकुलर चीज को तो हम इसको यहां
पे कॉपी कर लेते हैं सिंपल सा फंडा है
ठीक है यहां पर हम पेस्ट कर लेते
हैं इसको मैं रिमूव कर देता हूं इस लाइन
को दो बार हो गई है ठीक है डन अब यहां प
पिंग बैकड पिंग हो गया अब यहां पे एक पिंग
हमें हमें पिंग रिक्वेस्ट को देखनी है कि
भैया हमारा पिंग रिक्वेस्ट सक्सेसफुल हो
रहा है कि नहीं हो रहा पि पिंग हमें जा आ
रही है कि नहीं आ रही है तो इसके लिए हम
एक वेबसाइट यूज करेंगे पोस्ट
बिन पोस्ट बिन पोस्ट बिन क्या होता है कि
लाइक एपीआई रिक्वेस्ट अगर कहीं प आ रही
आपके तो आपको एक यूआरएल देगा एक सिंपल यूज
पोस्ट बिन टू कलेक्ट ऑल रिक्वेस्ट टू ए
स्पेसिफिक यूआरएल व्हिच यू कैन यूज टू
टेस्ट योर एपीआई क्लाइंट्स और योर वेब
हुक्स ठीक है तो चलिए हम यहां पे एक बिन
क्रिएट कर देते हैं हमने एक बिन क्रिएट
किया अब यहां पे हम एक हमें हमारी एक लिंक
मिल चुकी है यह वाली ठीक है तो हमने इस
लिंक को कॉपी कर लिया और इस लिंक को हम
यहां पे पेस्ट कर
देंगे इस लिंक को हम यहां
पे पेस्ट कर देंगे तो हमने पेस्ट कर लिया
लिंक को ठीक है डन और यहां पे example.com
के जगह पे हमारा क्या हो जाएगा जो हमारा
यूआरएल है वो हो जाएगा तो हमारा यूआरएल
क्या है भाई kct.ac.in
ठीक है ड आयन हैड कॉ को हटा देते हैं
सिंपल ठीक है डन तो हमारा जो यूआरएल है
kct.ac.in हो गया पि बैकड पिंग हम कर रहे
हैं यहां पे पोस्ट बीड आ हमने यह यूआरएल
डाल दिया अब हम जब इसको गो पे क्लिक
करेंगे अगर यह पिंग बैक रिसीव कर रहा है
तो हमें यहां पे इस पर्टिकुलर जगह पे
रिक्वेस्ट एक आ जाएगी दिख नो रिक्वेस्ट
रिसीवड अभी आ रहा है यहां पर रिक्वेस्ट
दिखनी चाहिए ठीक है समझ में आ रहा है चलिए
तोब हम यहां पर क्या कर देते गो पर क्लिक
कर देते हैं लेट्स
सी एंड या सो जैसे हमने गो पर क्लिक किया
200 ओके आ रहा है य याद रखिएगा 200 ओके वी
आर गेटिंग वी आर गेटिंग द रिस्पांस 200
ओके क्या हुआ
भाई ठीक है य पर के आ रहा य प अब हम देखते
हैं यहां पर पोस्ट बन में हमारे यहां पर
कुछ रिक्वेस्ट आई है कि नहीं आई है ठीक है
तो हम यहां पर क्या करते हैं सभी सभी को
समझ में आ रहा है ना भैया एवरीवन गेटिंग
अंडरस्टैंडिंग समझ में तो आ रहा है ना
आपको बता दीजिए एक बार जल्दी
से जल्दी बताइए एक
बार ओके
हां जी पाकिस्तान से कर सकते हैं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं
है तो यहां पे अब हम रीलोड करेंगे रीलोड
करेंगे तो यहां पर हमें एक रिक्वेस्ट आनी
चाहिए अगर रिक्वेस्ट आ गई है तो अच्छी बात
है नहीं आई है तो फिर दिक्कत है चलिए एक
बार रिक्वेस्ट देखते हैं यहां पे अभी कोई
रिक्वेस्ट नहीं आई है
वई
अ इज एवरीथिंग
गुड ओके लेट्स सी इफ यू आर गेटिंग द
रिक्वेस्ट
पोस्ट
बिन चलिए वापस एक बार हम यह यल देते यहां
पे ठीक है पोस्ट ड आ बन हो गया यहां पे
एंड एसटीटी पीएस है ना यार केसीटी एड आ का
क्या है यूआरएल क्या है केसीटी एटीटीपी एस
केसीटी एड आ ठीक
है केसीटी एड आन ओके इसको हम रिमूव कर
देते हैं स्ल एक आ गया तो को एंड यहां पर
गो प क्लिक करते हैं दोबारा चेक कर लेते
एक बार ठीक है एक बार फिर से रीलोड करते
पोस्ट बिन को यहां
पर नो वी आर नॉट गेटिंग द रिजल्ट्स हमें
यहां पर रिजल्ट तो नहीं मिल
रहा ओके कोई बात नहीं एक बार बर्प कोलबेट
का यूज कर ले क्या बर्प सूट में चलते हैं
यहां पे बर्प कोलबेट क्लाइंट प चलते हैं
यहां पे एंड यहां पर कॉपी टू क्लिप बोर्ड
कर लेते हैं एंड लेट्स गिव इट
यर ब क्लाइंट का यूआरएल दे देते हैं एक
बार ठीक है एंड यहां पे गो पे क्लिक करते
हैं ठीक है नाउ पॉल नाउ लेट्स पॉल नाउ इफ
यू आर गेटिंग एनी
रिजल्ट्स अ ना नहीं मिला हमें नहीं मिला
मतलब यहां पे
हमें रिस्पांस यहां पे नहीं मिल रहा
पर्टिकुलर इस बिन के लिए हमने किया यहां
पे तो यह इंटरेक्ट पिंग बैक के लिए नहीं
कर रहा है ठीक है चलिए अच्छी बात है यह
नहीं कर रहा कोई बात नहीं अब हम एक काम
करेंगे अब हम एक दूसरे टारगेट को भी ट्राई
करेंगे दूसरा टारगेट हमारा कौन सा ले ले
फूट फॉरेस्ट इसको ले लेते हैं इसको भी हम
एक बार चेक कर लेते हैं चेक तो करना
हमारा धर्म है
है हो सकता है इस पर ना हो रहा हो तो ल
ट्राई ऑन सेकंड
टारगेट
रीलोड आ गया राइट क्लिक सेंड टू रिपीटर
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देते हैं रिपीटर पर
चलते हैं राइट क्लिक करते हैं चेंज
रिक्वेस्ट मेथड पर करते हैं प क्लिक करते
हैं एंड हमें आ चुका सब कुछ यहां पर मिल
चुका है यहां पे सॉरी
[संगीत]
सॉरी एंड नाउ वी आर गोइंग टू कॉपी दिस
पेस्ट
इट इसको वर्जन यह वाली हटा देते हैं एक
बार ठीक है मेथड कॉल आ गया यहां पे अब
यहां पे हम पोस्ट बिन वाली दे देते हैं
अपनी पोस्ट बिन जो हमारी यूआरएल है वो
यूआरएल प्रोवाइड कर देते हैं
भैया सो वी आर गिविंग द पोस्ट बिन यूआरएल
सो लेट्स गिव इट
[संगीत]
हियर हां तो हमने दे दिया यहां पे और
हमारा यहां पे वेबसाइट जो है वह क्या है
कौन सा है
भैया
एचटीटीपीएस
डडड फ्रूट एफ आर य आईटी फ्रूट फड आ यही था
फट forest.in चलिए अच्छी बात है अब यहां प
गो प क्लिक कर देते हैं लेट्स सी व्ट इज
हैपनिंग ठीक है नाउ लेट्स सी इफ गेटिंग द
रिजल्ट्स
नो तो इसमें भी हमें नहीं मिल रहा तो इट्स
नॉट डूइंग पिंग बैक पिंग बैकड पिंग मेथड
नेम यहां पर ठीक है एंड हमने पोस्ट बन
वाली यूआरएल भी दे दी है सब कुछ सही दिया
हमने पोस्ट मेथड हमने कर दिया है फिर व्ट
इज द दिक्कत
कमिंग क्या दिक्कत हो सकती है एक बार गो
पर क्लिक करते फिर से
नहीं स्लैश का तो ऐसा कुछ इशू नहीं है देख
लेते एक
बार वी आर नॉट गेटिंग हियर तो हमें यहां
पर तो नहीं मिल रहा इसमें
भी तो एक काम करते हैं बॉब कबोट क्लाइंट
का मैं एक बार और यूज कर लेता हूं यहां
पे यूआरएल के
लिए ठीक है एंड लेट्स क्लिक ऑन
गो अरे यह बॉब कोलैबोरेटर क्लाइंट है ना
तो इधर आ जाते हैं पॉल नाउ करते
हैं कोई रिस्पांस नहीं आ
रहा तो एसटीडी पी टारगेट क्यों आ रहा है
भाई होस्ट यहां पे यह है
एंड
डीपीएस फूट फरेस्ट आ बिल्कुल सही है सो
व्हाट इज द इशू दैट वी आर
गेटिंग अ
नहीं नहीं एडीपी हटा के ऐसे कोई इशू तो
नहीं है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं होगी ए हटाने
से कोई दिक्कत नहीं होगा शायद मेरे ख्याल
से एक बार देख लेते हैं ठीक है ऐसा कोई
इशू नहीं है मैं पोस्ट बिन वाली कर लेता
हूं ठीक है पोस्ट बिन वाली रिक्वेस्ट को
क्या कर देते
हैं कॉपी कर लेते हैं एंड लेट्स ट्राई इट
आउट ओके ी शुड बी गेटिंग द रिस्पांस यर
ना ओके एक काम कर लेते
हैं मैं यहां पे पोस्ट बिन क्रिएट करता
हूं पोस्ट
बिन लेट्स क्रिएट दिस क्रिएट अ बिन अगेन
दूसरा एक क्रिएट करते हैं एंड यहां पे
इसको यूज करते हैं उस बिन
को ओके कोलैबोरेटर क्लाइंट को बंद कर देते
हैं फिलहाल के लिए
वी आर यूजिंग दिस वन दिस वन दिस वन एंड
दिस दिस ठीक है हमने कर दिया यहां पे
एसटीपीएस कर लेते हैं एपस कॉलन स् w फट
forest.in ठीक है भैया एंड यहां पे गो प
क्लिक कर देते हैं लेट्स
सी लेट्स रीलोड इट नो वी आर नॉट गेटिंग
दिस सो या बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया
मैं बढ़िया हूं तो हमें यहां पर कोई
रिस्पांस नहीं मिल रहा इस दो टट इस टारगेट
से भी नहीं मिल रहा हमें तो एक बार एक इस
वाले टारगेट में अगेन एक बार ट्राई आउट कर
लेते हैं क्या दिक्कत है हमारे को क्या
दिक्कत है कहीं से भी ट्राई करो गो पर
क्लिक कर लेते हैं एक
बार ठीक है प्रीवियस वाला जो हमारा मेथड
था उसको एक बार करते हैं कॉल सिस्टम लिस्ट
मेथड हां जी तो पिंग बैक डॉट
पिंग पिंग बैक डॉट पिंग यह तो आ रही हमारी
ठीक है अच्छी बात है
ठीक है नाउ वी आर चेंजिंग द वैल्यू यहां
पर एंड केसीटी एड आ गो प क्लिक कर देते
हैं देखते
हैं ओके सो चलो इसमें तो नहीं आ रहा यह
वाली टारगेट प भी नहीं आ रही हमारी एक और
टारगेट थी हमारी एंड आईआरपी इंडिया ठीक है
इसको एक बार ट्राई आउट कर लेते हैं आईआरपी
वाले को टारगेट करते हैं भाई एक बार इसको
भी ट्राई आउट करके देख ही लेते हैं चलिए
इसको रीलोड करते हैं यहां पे इसको यहां
पकड़ते हैं एंड इसको राइट क्लिक करके हम
कहां भेजते हैं राइट क्लिक करके सेंड टू
रिपीटर इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ कर लेते हैं रिपीटर
पे चलते हैं ठीक है भैया रिपीटर पे आ गए
यहां पे गो पे क्लिक कर देते हैं अगेन वही
चीज आएगी कि पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट ओनली राइट
क्लिक करके चेंज रिक्वेस्ट मेथड पे क्लिक
कर देते हैं चलो गेट को यहां पे पोस्ट कर
देते हैं गेट को यहां पोस्ट कर देते हैं
गो पे क्लिक कर देते हैं एंड ट्स इट ठीक
है आ गया यहां पे चलो अब यहां पे सिंपल सा
हम लिस्ट मेथड्स वाली जो हमारी कमांड है
उसको यहां पर पेस्ट कर देते हैं सिंपल सा
एज इट इज एंड यहां गो पर क्लिक कर लेते
हैं एंड वी गट द लिस्ट यर नाउ यर पिंग बैक
डट पिंग इ वी आर गेटिंग तो पिंग बैक डॉट
पिंग वाली जो मेथड है इसको हम यहां पर एक
बार लिस्ट आउट कर देते हैं अगेन यहां
पे डाल देते
हैं ठीक है
तो यहां पर अब अगेन हम यहां पर पोस्ट बिन
वाली जो हमारी यूआरएल है यह यूआरएल
प्रोवाइड कर देते हैं जो हमारे पास यूआरएल
है इसको हमने यहां डाला एंड यर ड
प्रोवाइडेड यह आप लोग साथ में अगर कोई कर
रहा है तो
कीजिएगा अगर आपका वहां पर कुछ आ रहा है तो
तो यहां पर हम यूआरएल प्रोवाइड कर देते
हैं कौन स हमारी यूआरएल है
भाई यह यूआरएल है लेट्स प्रोवाइड इट र क
की जगह प हमारा यूआरएल प्रोवाइड कर देते
हैं ठीक है तो हमने यूआरएल दे दिया नाउ
लेट्स क्लिक ऑन गो एंड लेट्स सी व्ट इज
हैपनिंग तो हमने किया य पे फॉल्स स्ट्रिंग
ठीक है एंड लेट्स सी लेट्स रीलोड इट न सो
वी आर नॉट गेटिंग द पिंग बैक रिक्वेस्ट
करेंटली यहां
पे क्या हो रहा है सर मैं कर रहा हूं
बढ़िया बढ़िया कासम बढ़िया तो ये बेसिकली
क्या है ना एक सो व्हाट इज द यूज ऑफ बर्ब
कोबोट क्लाइंट देखो बर्ब कोलैबोरेटर
क्लाइंट क्या है ना जैसे अभी तुम ये पोस्ट
बिन का यूज कर रहे हो ना एक पर्टिकुलर
तुम्हें एक कहीं पे वेब पे एक पाथ दे दिया
अब उस पाथ को तुम रिक्वेस्ट भेजोगे तो वो
तुमको रिस्पांस मतलब बताएगा कि हां भैया
मैं इंटरेक्ट किया मैंने उस रिक्वेस्ट से
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट से तो आपको वहां पे
सामने दिखा देगा कि कहां से रिक्वेस्ट आई
है किसने भेजा है क्या पर्टिकुलर लाइक
यूजर एजेंट है ये सब डिटेल्स आईपीस किस
आईपी से मैंने इंटरेक्ट किया है उसकी
हेडर्स की डिटेल्स वो सब कुछ आपको
प्रोवाइड कर देगा रिक्वेस्ट की ठीक है बस
यह चीज़ है वही बर्ब क्ला अ जो आपका
बेसिकली बर्ब कोलबो मेटर क्लाइंट जो है
कुछ इसी तरीके का है आप टेंपरली एक यूआरएल
बेसिकली जनरेट करते हो एंड यू कैन जस्ट
कम्युनिकेट विद दैट पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल तो
मैंने यहां पे जैसे कॉपी किया मैंने यहां
पे बब क्लाइंट का यहां पे यूआरएल डाल दिया
अब मैं गो पे क्लिक करूंगा इसका मतलब वी
आर आई एम कम्युनिकेटिंग विद दिस पर्टिकुलर
पॉल नाऊ पे क्लिक करोगे तो यहां पे आपको
जो भी कम्युनिकेशन अगर होगी तो यहां पे
सामने दिख जाएगी ठीक है चलो यह तो अब
सिंपल सा फंडा है यह तो हमने क्या किया कि
हमने एक पिंग बैक पिंग मेथड को चेक किया
यहां पे अभी फिलहाल ये इंटरेक्ट नहीं हो
रहा बट नॉर्मली इसको इंटरेक्ट करना चाहिए
नॉर्मली ऐसा नहीं होना चाहिए इंटरेक्ट
करना चाहिए आई डोंट नो कि इंटरेक्ट क्यों
नहीं कर रहा बट ठीक है चलेगा कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है हमारे पास अभी और भी चीजें हैं जो
हम अभी ट्राई आउट करने वाले हैं तो हम
सबसे पहले क्या करते हैं ना फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट
वाली कौन सी है ये वाली है फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट
वाली ठीक है तो इसके हम प्रीवियस मेथड्स
पे जाते हैं जो हम ट्राई कर रहे थे हां ये
वाला हमने किया इस पे हम यहां पे लिस्ट
मेथड ट्राई कर लेते हैं लिस्ट मेथड एक बार
कर लेते
हैं तो यहां पे हमें आ रहा
है डेमो डॉट से हेलो इज वर्किंग फाइन
राइट डेमो डॉट से सॉरी डेमो डॉट से हेलो
इज वर्किंग एब्सलूट फाइन वी आर गेटिंग
हेलो हेलो फ्रॉम सर्वर बहुत बढ़िया तो ये
हमें मिल रहा है अब हम यहां पे एक काम
करते हैं व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू वी आर
गोइंग टू डू वी आर गोइंग टू ट्राई सम
टेक्निक्स फॉर द ब्रूट फोर्सिंग थिंग ठीक
है अब यहां पे आप देख सकते हो अ यहां पे
जैसे कि हमने किया था पिंग बैक यहां पे
करके तो वी वर गेटिंग द थिंग कि हमें ऐसा
रिजल्ट आ रहा था
एंड जो हमें मिल रहा था हमें इंटरेक्ट
करने के लिए हम देख पा रहे थे ठीक है अब
यहां पे हम एक पर्टिकुलर क्या करने वाले
हैं वी आर गोइंग अ फॉर अ काइंड ऑफ ब्रूट
फोर्स ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक करने के लिए ट्राई
हम करने वाले हैं ठीक है तो अब यहां पे
ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक करने के लिए देखो किस
तरीके से करना है यहां पे जैसे कि अ मान
लो कि जब तुम यहां पे ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक
करोगे तो यू कैन गिव योर यूजर नेम एंड
पासवर्ड फॉर दैट पर्टिकुलर अटैक ठीक है आप
यूजर नेम पासवर्ड दे सकते हो जैसे कि यहां
पे मेथड कॉल यहां पे सिम डॉट अ मल्टी कॉल
आ गया या मेथड नेम में आपका डब्ल्यूपी गेट
यूजर्स ब्लॉग आ गया या गेट यूजर्स अ
डब्ल्यूपी गेट यूजर्स ब्लॉग आ गया या
पर्टिकुलर गेट यूजर्स की डिटेल्स आ गई या
जो भी डिटेल्स यहां पे जो भी मेथड्स हैं
लिस्टेड यहां पे आप उनमें से कोई से भी
मेथड्स का यूज़ करके एंड आप ब्रूट फोर्स
के लिए ट्राई कर सकते हो यू कैन जस्ट
ट्राई आउट एनी विद एनी मेथड कोई भी मेथड
आप लो जिससे कि आप ब्लॉग से इंटरेक्ट करके
और उस तरीके से जैसे मान लो मैंने किया
ब्लॉगर
डॉट मान लो ब्लॉगर ड गेट यूजर इनो आया ठीक
है या ब्लॉगर ड गेट यूज ब्लॉग तो इसके
थ्रू हम क्या कर सकते हैं अपना वैल्यू
प्रोवाइड कर सकते हैं यूजर नेम पासवर्ड का
एंड वी कैन ट्राई टू हंट ऑन देम ठीक है तो
हम एक काम कर लेते हैं लेट्स ट्राई इट
आउट यहां पे एक चलिए यहां पे मीडियम
आर्टिकल है जो कि बहुत ही बेकार
है यहां पे किसी ने हैकर वन की रिपोर्ट
फाइल की है आप इस रिपोर्ट को भी देख सकते
हैं यू कैन जस्ट सी द रिपोर्ट टू गेट
ओवरव्यू यहां पे हैरन की कोई एक रिपोर्ट
है कि किसी ने रिपोर्ट की थी मीडियम में
एंड कब रिपोर्ट की थी यह
2000 22 में ठीक है तो यहां पे आया था कि
पब्लिश एक्सएमएल आरपीसी पिंग हो रहा है
ब्रिट फोर्स अटैक वा एक्सएमएल आरपीसी आ
रहा है ये सारी चीजें आ रही है ठीक है तो
यहां पे देयर आर सम रिसोर्सेस जो इन्होंने
दिए हुए हैं जो हम रिसोर्सेस हमने एक
रिसोर्स तो हमने इसमें से निकाला हुआ था
शायद कोई सा अ कोई एक जो भी है व्हाट एवर
तो यहां पे इन्होंने पूरा दिया हुआ है
यहां पे इनका जब ट्र ट्रैग हुआ था लाइक
ट्रैग हुआ था तो यहां पे इन्होंने ये फॉलो
किया हुआ था तो बेसिकली इसमें सिंपल सा हम
एक कोड उठा लेते हैं ठीक है एंड दैट कोड
इज फॉर ब्रूट फोर्सिंग ठीक है तो यहां पे
हम रूट फोर्सिंग के लिए एक उठा लेते हैं
कौन सा ये वाला उठा लेते हैं पिंग बैक का
तो हमने कर लिया था हां चलो यह वाला उठा
लेते हैं ये वाला सिंपल सा कोड उठा लेते
हैं ठीक है यहां पे ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के लिए
अब यहां पे ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के लिए क्या
करना है गाइस आपको सिंपल सा यूजर नेम एंड
आपका पासवर्ड देना है बस सिंपल सा फंडा
जैसे हमने क्या किया यहां पे हम यहां पे
लिस्ट मेथड कर रहे थे ना नाउ हियर वी गिवन
हियर नाउ हियर या इस तरीके से आप यहां पे
दे सकते हो यहां पे यूजर नेम अपना दे दो
वैल्यू में एंड यहां पे पासवर्ड दे दो ठीक
है वैल्यू आपको यहां पे डिफाइन कर यूजर
नेम एंड पासवर्ड बस
दैट्ची पीच ना हो सिंपल वैल्यू ही देनी है
और कुछ नहीं करना वो ब्रैकेट ट देख के डर
मत जाना आप लोग सिंपल सा ये वाला समझ लो
ठीक है तो यहां पे वैल्यू देना है यहां पे
यूजर नेम एंड यहां पे पासवर्ड देना है एंड
यहां पे जो हम यूज कर रहे मेथड वो है
डब्लू पड गट यूजर्स ब्लॉग ठीक है गेट
यूजर्स ब्लॉग करना है एंड यहां पे हमें
क्या करना है वैल्यू देनी है ठीक है 20
20000 हो गए क्या भाई सच में हो गए क्या
20000 देखते हैं 20000 सब्सक्राइबर्स हो
चुके हैं शायद तो लेट्स
सी य स्टूडियो खोल देता हूं आप लोगों के
सामने एनालिटिक्स भी आप लोगों के सामने
खोल देते हैं कोई बात नहीं चलेगा इतना
क्या बात है क्या बात है गाइस सो 20000
सब्सक्राइबर्स डन अचीव्ड एंड खतरनाक मतलब
20000 हो चु चुके हमारे सब्सक्राइबर्स सो
सबसे पहले तो कांग्रेचुलेशन टू ईच वन ऑफ
यू जो सपोर्ट करते हैं जो कंटेंट्स को
शेयर करते हैं अपने ग्रुप्स में या अपने
दोस्तों के भी जिनको जरूरत है इस कंटेंट
की या इन कंटेंट्स की एंड जिनका भी सपोर्ट
है जो भी व्हाट एवर उन सबको बहुत-बहुत
धन्यवाद ठीक है हां एक और चीज जो थोड़े
हेट्स टाइप के हैं थोड़े से डाइजेस्ट नहीं
कर पाते हमारी चीजों को उनको भी धन्यवाद
क्योंकि एटलीस्ट उनका भी यहां आके देखते
हैं वो भी इंटरेक्ट करते हैं इंगेजमेंट
बढ़ाते हैं तो उनका भी एक रोल है तो हेट्स
उनको भी धन्यवाद एंड सपोर्टर्स को तो दिल
से एकदम बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद तो मेनी मेनी
कांग्रेचुलेशन टू एवरी बडी सो वी आर नाइ
20000 सब्सक्राइबर्स मार्क धन्यवाद भाई
कांग्रेचुलेशन धन्यवाद सबको धन्यवाद भाई
भाई कौन देख रहा था यार यह 200 हज वाला
देख कौन रहा
था सबसे पहले हैक स्किल ने बताया हैक
स्किल ने सबसे पहले बताया बहुत बढ़िया
चलिए बाकी लोग ने फिर
किया 10k के टाइम में भी थे क्या बात है
चलिए अच्छी बात है चलिए तो हमने फाइनली
20000 वाला अचीव कर ही लिया है अ एंड अब
जो है
ठीक है भाई
चलिए तो गेट यूजर्स ब्लॉग में हम यहां पर
एडमिन एंड पासवर्ड ठीक है वैल्यू देंगे
ब्रूट फोर्स करेंगे इसके एडमिन के लिए
पासवर्ड के लिए वी विल ब्रूट फोर्स तो
हमें अगर एडमिन पता है मतलब यार हमें तो
एडमिन पता है ना कि एडमिन कौन सा
है फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट के लिए या जो भी है यूजर
का नाम पता है तो फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट के लिए हम
यहां पर क्या करेंगे यूजर का नाम डाल
देंगे हमें क्या मिला था यूजर का
देख लेते यहां पर कौन सी मिली थी
भाई डब्ल्यूपी जेसन वजन यूजर्स ठीक
है तो हमें मिला था फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट आयन ही
करके मिला था शायद जो एक यूजर
था आशा वेटेक आईटी सलूशन कॉ इसमें ट्राई
कीजिए क्या बात है खुद का ही वेबसाइट दे
रहा है बंदा अच्छी बात है चलो तो यहां पे
एक यूजर नेम था यहां पे फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट
राइट यह रहा फूट फॉरेस्ट फूट फरेस्ट इन तो
फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट इन यूजर नेम हमारे पास
ऑलरेडी पता है भाई तो हम यहां पे यूजर नेम
एडमिन की जगह पे क्या डाल देते हैं फ्रूट
फॉरेस्ट इन ये डाल देते हैं ठीक है एक
एडमिन यूजर भी है याद रखिएगा एडमिन भी
यूजर है अब इसको चेक आउट कैसे कर सकते हैं
ना आप जैसे कि आप क्या करो डब्ल्यूपी हान
एडमिन पे करके इस इनके एडमिन पैनल पे जाओ
ठीक है एडमिन पैनल प जाओ और मान लो यहां
पे तुमने यूजर नेम डाला डि फ्रक्स मान लो
और पासवर्ड में कुछ भी डाल दिया अब यहां
पे लॉगइन करो तुम लॉगइन जब करोगे ना तो
यहां आएगा अननोन यूजर नेम मतलब यह यूजर
नेम एजिस्ट नहीं करती है समझ में आ रहा है
दैट्ची पे अगर डालो फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट इन क्या
है फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट इन एंड पासवर्ड कुछ भी
डालो एंड देन लॉग इन करो एंड देन देखो
क्या होता है द पासवर्ड इ एंटर्ड फॉर
यूजरनेम फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट इज इनकरेक्ट इसका
मतलब क्या है कि भैया यह यूजर नेम एजिस्ट
करता है तभी
पासवर्ड अच्छा मिल रहा है बहुत बढ़िया मिल
रहा है तो अच्छी बात
है चलिए अच्छी बात है ठीक है तो यहां पे
इसका मतलब ये यूजर नेम अवेलेबल है क्या
अवेलेबल है भाई ये यूजर नेम अवेलेबल है
उसी तरीके से एडमिन के लिए देखो इस
पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट पे एडमिन भी होगा एडमिन
तो डिफॉल्ट जनरली रहता है तो पासवर्ड फॉर
एंटर्ड यूजर नेम एडमिन इज इनकरेक्ट तो
यानी एडमिन भी है अब करो फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट
ओनली डालो ओनली फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट डाल के
देखते हैं है कि नहीं फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट भी है
ठीक है फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट भी है ठीक है भाई
मार्केटिंग टेक करते हैं करते हैं रुक जाओ
रुक जाओ फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट भी है तो इस पे भी
हम कर सकते हैं तो हमारे पास एक यूजर नेम
है फूट फॉस्ट आयन एंड वी हैव वी डोंट नो द
पासवर्ड वी डोंट नो द पासवर्ड अब मुझे
बताओ कि इसको ब्रूट फोर्स करना है हमें तो
इसको ब्रूट फोर्स हम बहुत सिंपली कैसे कर
सकते हैं
बताइए
बताइए डू यू थिंक देयर इज अ गुड फ्यूचर
फॉर ओसिंट इन्वेस्टिगेटर एंड साइबर क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेटर बिल्कुल बिल्कुल है आपका
बहुत बहुत फ्यूचर है डिपेंड करता है आप
किस तरह से उसको होल्ड करके एंड आगे बढ़
रहे हैं सब कुछ उस परे डिपेंड करता
है बिल्कुल वी कैन यूज द इंट्रूडर फंक्शन
तो राइट क्लिक करके सेंड टू इंट्रूडर पे
हम इसको भेज देते हैं इंट्रूडर पे चलते
हैं यहां पे पोजीशंस पे चलते हैं यहां पे
क्लियर कर लेते हैं अब यहां पे हमें पता
है यूजर नेम एडमिन है यहां पे या फ्रूट
फॉरेस्ट आईन करके है यहां पे हम इसको
एडमिन भी कर सकते हैं क्योंकि एक एडमिन
नाम का भी यूजर है ठीक है याद रखिएगा बट
फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट इनका भी है तो हम एडमिन
वाला यूजर जो है इसको हम मेंशन कर देते
हैं एडमिन और पासवर्ड हमें नहीं पता है तो
पासवर्ड के जगह पे हम चाहते हैं कि हमारे
पास एक लिस्ट हो पासवर्ड की राइट हमारे
पास एक पासवर्ड के लिस्ट हो एंड हम उस परे
ट्राई आउट करें ये हम एक बात देखना चाहते
हैं करेक्ट तो हम क्या कर देते हैं गा व्ट
वी आर गोइंग टू डू वी आर गोइंग टू चूज
सिलेक्ट द पासवर्ड एंड वी आर गोइंग
टू ऐड यहां पर ऐड कर देते हैं पर्टिकुलर
चीज के लिए पासवर्ड के लिए य पर ऐड कर
दिया हमने अब यहां पर अटैक कौन सा चूज
करें यह बताइए अटैक कौन सा चूज करें यह
बता दीजिए आप लोग च टाइप ऑफ अटैक आई शुड
यूज इनमें से कौन सा अटैक यूज होना
चाहिए बिल्कुल स्पर स्निपर क्योंकि हमने
एक टारगेट को यहां पे एक अ एक ही वैल्यू
जो है हमने यहां पे डिफाइन किया जिसको
जिसकी वैल्यूज को हम चेंज कर रहे हैं मतलब
अलग-अलग अपने पेलोड्स के लिए तो हम पे
लोट्स पे जाएंगे यहां पे अब पेलेट्स पे
आने के बाद यहां पे लिस्ट आ रही है तो भै
आपको लिस्ट यहां पे चाहिए पासवर्ड की
लिस्ट व पासवर्ड के लिस्ट जब यहां पे आप
डालोगे तो यहां पे आप ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक
शुरू कर सकते हो तो चलिए अब पासवर्ड के
लिस्ट कहां से लाते हैं तो पासवर्ड के
लिस्ट लाने के लिए बहुत सारी ऑप्शंस हैं
हम उसपे ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं ठीक है वी
कैन जस्ट गिव इट अ
ट्राई ओके सो यहां पे कर देते हैं
कॉमन पासवर्ड
लिस्ट ठीक है कॉमन पासवर्ड लिस्ट पर चलते
हैं 10 मिलियन पासवर्ड ये मतलब यह कुछ
ज्यादा ही हो गया
पासवर्ड 10
मिलियन टॉप 200 मोस्ट कॉमन पासवर्ड लिस्ट
देखते हैं यहां पे कौन सा
है ओके तो यहां पर हमारे पास टॉप 200 कॉमन
पासवर्ड लिस्ट है डाउनलोड शद हो जाए तो
अच्छी बात है अगर इजली हो जाए तो देखते
हैं यहां पर आई डोंट थिंक किय इस तरीके से
कॉपी ओके 2022 का यहां पर लिस्ट
है ओके यह पूरी की पूरी कॉपी हो रही है तो
काम करते हैं ना यहां से ही कॉपी कर लेते
हैं इसको डायरेक्ट अगर यह कॉपी हो जाए
तो ओ ये पूरी की पूरी आ जाएगी चलो हटाओ
यहां पे 10 मिलियन पासवर्ड लिस्ट है यहां
पे इस पर चल देते हैं एक
बार 50 मोस्ट कॉमन रि मप पासवर्ड टॉप 200
मोस्ट कॉमन पासवर्ड ठीक है यहां पर चल
देते हैं शायद डायरेक्टली दिया हो तो
अच्छी बात है अरवाज यहां पे लिस्ट है यहां
पे बहुत लंबी लिस्ट है ये 10000 लाइंस की
लिस्ट है तो इसको हम एक बार कॉपी कर लेते
हैं कॉपी करके यहां पे बब शूट के अंदर
यहां पे पेस्ट कर देते हैं तो यहां पे
पेस्ट करके हमने यहां पे पासवर्ड डाल दिया
है ठीक है वी एंटर द पासवर्ड
वी आर नाउ गोइंग टू स्टार्ट 10000 काउंट
है तो हम यहां पे इसको पर्टिकुलर अटैक को
स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं ठीक है तो स्टार्ट
टक क्लिक कर देते हैं एंड देन आवर टैक विल
बी स्टार्टेड याद रखिएगा जब अटैक आपकी चल
रही हो तो एक बात का ध्यान रखिएगा कि जीरो
नंबर पे जीरो नंबर पे जो भी लेंथ है 677
इससे डिफरेंट लेंथ होना चाहिए एंड जब कोई
करेक्ट पासवर्ड मिलेगी य 200 स्टेटस कोड
देख के इस परे मत आप फिदा हो जाइएगा इसपे
फिदा होने की जरूरत नहीं है आपको जब आपको
लेंथ में अचानक से कोई वेरिएशन देखने को
मिले इसका मतलब है उस पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट
के लिए कुछ ना कुछ तो डिफरेंट है तभी लेंथ
में इतना वेरिएशन आ रहा है तो अगर
सक्सेसफुल लॉगिन होता है या सक्सेसफुल
यहां पे आपका कुछ पासवर्ड मिलता है तो
उसकी लेंथ जो होगी ये यह बिल्कुल डिफरेंट
होगी ठीक है भैया तो जस्ट लेट इट ट्राई
इसको ट्राई करने दीजिएगा एंड 10000 जैसे
ही यह ट्राई कर लेगा फिर ये देखेगा कि
भैया कुछ मिला कि नहीं मिला ट्राई करेगा
राइट
ओके ओके लेट्स
सी हा जी लेंथ में लेंथ में इशू है तो
लेंथ वाली चीज
प लेंथ लेंथ लेंथ इ वट मैटर्स लेंथ ही
मैटर करता है कंटेंट की लेंथ मैटर करती है
जो भी आपकी रिक्वेस्ट रिपस आप रिस्पांस जो
भी आपका आता है
बिल्कुल सही इंपैक्ट के बिना कुछ भी नहीं
है भाई इंपैक्ट के बिना कुछ नहीं है
इंपैक्ट होना चाहिए इंपैक्ट के बिना कुछ
भी नहीं है बिल्कुल सही बात
है कोई भी वनबिल रिपोर्ट करोगे इंपैक्ट
अगर सही नहीं है उसका इंपैक्टफुल अच्छे से
इंपैक्ट नहीं कर पा रहा है तो उसका कोई
वैल्यू उसकी कोई भी वैल्यू नहीं है जीरो
वैल्यू ऑफ दैट पर्टिकुलर थिंग ठीक है तो
इसको चलने देते हैं यह आपको समझ में आ रहा
होगा कि हम इस यहां पर एक ब्रूट फोर्स
अटैक कर रहे हैं ताकि हम और और भी आगे
बढ़ते हैं और भी चीजें हैं करने को बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें हैं वो हम करते हैं ठीक
है तो चलिए कहां गए थे हम कहां गए थे तो
हमने यहां पे एक्सप्लोइट किया ठीक है भैया
सिंपल सा फंडा है इससे आप और भी चीजें कर
सकते हैं लाइक काइंड ऑफ थिंग दैट यू कैन
डू
सो पिंक बैक वाली चीज नहीं आई यार वो इसको
आनी चाहिए थी पिंग बैक वाली सिंपल सी
सिंपल सा फंडा था य शुड बी गेटिंग पिंग
बैक रिक्वेस्ट बट ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
यहां पे लेट्स कॉपी दिस वंस अगेन गाइस
लेट्स कॉपी
दि कौन सा ये फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट है ना एक बार
और कॉपी कर लेते हैं यहां पे एंड यर लेट्स
गिव इट अ ट्रा लेट्स कॉपी द ट टिक टिक
टिक लेट्स पेस्ट
ट चलिए हमने पेस्ट किया फूट फड आय प एंड
यहां पर अब हम जो कर लेते हैं ना पि बैकड
पि कर लिया हमने पि बकड एक्सटेंशन गेट
पिंग
बैक लेस गव ट
ट्राई चलिए यहां पे नाउ लेट्स चेक ऑन
दिस चलो कोई बात नहीं पे कुछ नहीं आया
यहां पे पोस्ट है ना ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
चलिए तो यहां पे आप ट्राई कीजिएगा मे बी
यू गेट द पिंग बैक कुछ अगर पिंग बैक अगर
आपको मिल गया तो अच्छी बात है तो वो बस एक
पिंग बैक हो गया कि हां आपको दिखाने के
लिए कि भैया हां भाई हम पिंग बैक आपको
हमको मिल रहा है हालांकि हमने डेमो से
हेलो कर दिया था तो हमें डेमो से हेलो का
हेलो रिप्लाई सर्वर से आ चुका था एंड यहां
पे हमारी करेंटली जो है ब्रूट फोर्स जो है
वो चल रही है एंड कोई कंटेंट लेंथ में किछ
किसी कंटेंट लेंथ में कोई चेंज दिख रहा है
आपको आईम नॉट गेटिंग एनी चेंज कोई चेंज तो
नहीं दिख रहा कुछ खास चेंज नहीं दिख रहा
चलिए कोई बात नहीं कोई चलेगा इतना चलेगा
ठीक है तो चलिए अब यहां पे हम एक बार आ
जाते हैं काली
पे हां जी तो काली प आ गया हमें अलग-अलग
यूजर्स मिले थे यहां पे य यू कैन सी यर कि
हमें यहां पर अलग-अलग यूजर्स मिले हैं तो
इसको हम यहां पे क्लियर कर देते हैं अब एक
चीज और आपको देखनी है एक चीज और आपको करनी
है क्या करनी है मैं आपको बताता हूं आपको
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
से आप इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल सकते हो वर्डप्रेस
की वेबसाइट्स पे यू कैन डू दिस थिंग आल्सो
तो आपको डायरेक्टरीज भी फाइंड करनी है
भैया अब जैसे कि व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू से
जैसे कि मान लो हमारा एक हमारा जो टारगेट
है क्या है टारगेट
हमारा kct.ac.in ये हमारा टारगेट है हमने
इसको ओपन किया
ठीक है अब यहां पे काली में एक टूल है
डीआई आर बर डीआई आर बर इसको हम ओपन कर
लेते
हैं ठीक है सो वी ओपन द डी बस्टर अब हमें
यहां पे टारगेट यूआरएल मेंशन करनी है तो
हम यहां पे टारगेट यूआरएल मेंशन कर देते
हैं भैया कॉपी किया यहां से टारगेट यूआरएल
एंड डीआर बस्टर में हमने यहां पे डाल दिया
अब यहां पे सिंपल यहां पे पोर्ट नंबर आपको
बताना है तो बता दीजिए आपकी मर्जी है मतलब
आपकी मर्जी है पोर्ट नंबर बताना है बताइए
जो भी करना है कीजिए तो हमने यहां पे
टारगेट एक मेंशन कर दिया है ठीक है अब
यहां पे हमें एक एक फाइल्स चाहिए जो
डायरेक्टरी की फाइल्स होती है वोह चाहिए
तो वह आपको मिल जाएगी यूएसआर के अंदर आपको
मिल जाएगी यूएसआर के अंदर शेयर के अंदर
डीआर बस्टर सर्च करो डीआर बस्टर डीर बस्टर
के अंदर वर्डलिस्ट के अंदर एंड यहां से
कोई सा भी लाइक आप वड लिस्ट उठा लीजिए
डायरेक्टरी लिस्ट 1.0 डायरेक्टरीज जेबी
फोब डायरेक्टरी स्मॉल केस लोअर केस स्मॉल
यह वाला स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं एक बार ठीक
है तो ये हमने किया एंड यहां पे हम यहां
पे स्टार्ट पे क्लिक कर देंगे तो जब हम
स्टार्ट पे क्लिक करेंगे तो यू विल सी ये
डायरेक्टरी सर्च करना शुरू कर देगा
बेसिकली इस पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट के लिए एंड
यहां पे देख सकते हो टाइम फिनिश टू टाइम
टू फिनिश वन डे आ रहा है यहां पे एंड यहां
पे रिजल्ट्स फर्स्ट व्यूज जो है ना इसको
ओपन कर लीजिए रिजल्ट वाले में अब यहां पे
जब तुम रिजल्ट वाली ओपन करोगे तो यहां पे
तुम्हें अलग-अलग रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे यहां पे
अब देखो यहां पे अब यहां पे रिस्पांस 200
एक मिल रहा है चलिए अच्छी बात है यहां
पे 20 कंसेक्युटिव एरर्स हैज हैपेंड तो
यहां पे दो 20 एरर्स के लिए यहां पे ये
रोक रहा था इसलिए इसने अपने आप को स्टॉप
किया हुआ था चलिए कोई बात नहीं ये फिर से
स्टार्ट हो जाएगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक
है तो एरर्स आई थी इसलिए तो अब यहां पे
आपको रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे अलग-अलग डायरेक्टरी
जो है ना आपको मिलेंगे जो हो सकता है कुछ
यूनिक डायरेक्टरी जो है आपको मिल जाए यहां
पे कुछ यूनिक चीजें आपको मिल जाए ठीक है
तो आपको यहां पे भी ये भी ट्राई करना है
जैसे कि यहां पे मुझे एक कुछ मिला है क्या
ना कुछ खास तो नहीं मिला यहां पे
मिल रहा
है यहां पर आपको स्कैन इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी
य विल से स्कैन इंफॉर्मेशन
जो भी स्कैन और यहां पे लिस्ट व्यू आपको
मिलेगी जो भी है तो इस तरीके से आप
डायरेक्टरी बस्टर का भी यूज कर सकते हैं
जो भी डायरेक्टरी बस्टर का यूज करना अगर
चाहते हैं तो आप इस तरह से डायरेक्टरी ये
काफी टाइम ले लेता है अगर आप इसको यूज
करेंगे डायरेक्टरी बस्टर को तो तो इसमें
आप करके एकएक फाइल को स्कैन करके मतलब
एकएक डायरेक्टरी को स्कैन करके आप उस के
अंदर छिपी हुई चीजों को निकाल सकते हैं
जैसे सिंपली डायरेक्टरी बूट फोर्स आप करते
हैं डी सर्च वगैरह से वैसे करके वैसे ही
आप इस पर ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं अब मैं
आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं जब भी आप
वर्डप्रेस हंटिंग कर रहे इसका मतलब यह
नहीं है कि यह कुछ अलग है या बाकी वेबसाइट
से डिफरेंट है थोड़ी चीजें जो वर्डप्रेस
की फंक्शनैलिटी है वह बस अलग है जिसकी वजह
से आपको कुछ अलग चीजें करने को मौका
मिलेगा बट जनरली जब आप वर्डप्रेस हंटिंग
भी करते
हैं ठीक है तो आप उसके लिए फाइंड और द सब
डोमेन ऑफ ट ऑफ द टारगेट डोमेन टारगेट
डोमेन य आपको पूरा सब डोमेन फाइंड कर लेनी
है फाइंड ऑल
द
आईपी रिलेटेड जो भी आपकी रिलेटेड आईपी है
वह फाइंड कर लेना उसके रिगार्डिंग ठीक है
हंट ऑन
दोस एंड
आईपी ठीक है ट्राई टू फाइंड सेंसिटिव
डायरेक्टरीज जो भी डायरेक्टरीज है उसके
बाद ट्राई टू
फाइंड वल्नरेबल
प्लगिंस एंड थीम्स यह आपको ट्राई करना है
फाइंड करने का कि वल्नरेबल प्लगिंस या
वल्नरेबल थीम्स जो है हम को कुछ मिल जाए
पर्टिकुलर वे पर्टिकुलर चीज के को लेके
हमें वो मिले ठीक है तो ये आपको ट्राई
करना है तो यू कैन ट्राई डिफरेंट थिंग्स
यूज़ सीएए
मैप टूल सीएमए m
एंड डप स्कैन
टूल अलोंग विथ n
m n मैप का भी आपको यूज़ करना है सीएए मैप
यूज़ करना है जो भी वने एबिलिटीज वगैरह
फाइंड करनी है उसके लिए आपको फाइंड आपको
ट्राई करना है जैसे हमारे पास एक टारगेट
है हमारे पास कौन सा टारगेट है भाई हमारे
पास जो टारगेट है वह है के k एड आ ठीक है
ये हमारा टारगेट है केसीटी एड आ तो हम
क्या कर देते हैं चलते हैं यहां पे मान लो
ए यहां प हम सीएमएस मैप को ओपन कर लेते
हैं एंड सीएमएस मैप के बाद यहां पर हम
क्या कर लेते हैं यह वाली फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट ा
देते
हैं यहां पर हम डाल देते हैं केसीटी एड आ
केड एड आ ये हमने किया और हम एंटर कर देते
हैं जब एंटर करेंगे तो यहां पे आ रहा है
क्या एरर आ रही है तो हमें यहां पे पूरा
ही नाम देना पड़ेगा मेरे ख्याल से तो
एचटीटीपीएस कॉल
केसीटी एड आ एंड लेट्स सी तो टारगेट यहां
पे आ गया इसकी आईपी आ गई यहां पे 188 17
ये वाली आईपी आ गई अब इस आईपी को हमने
कॉपी किया नया टैब ओपन किया ए मैप न ए बी
एंड यहां पेय आईपी डाल दी अब इस आईपी पे
भी इधर टारगेट चला दिया इधर हमने इस पर
चला दिया कौन सी चला दिया
भैया यह वाली चला दी ठीक है अब यह वाली
अपनी काम अपना काम कर रहा है सीएमएस मैप
अपना काम कर रहा है यह कौन सा आपका सीएमएस
मैप आपका काम कर रहा है यहां पे आपका ए
मैप काम कर रहा है और यहां पे हमने
डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन चला दिया तो हमने क्या
किया यहां पे अब डब्लू स्कैन में भी बहुत
सारी चीजें है अब देखो यहां पे डब्ल्यूपी
स्कैन में तुम सारी चीजें एक साथ कर सकते
हो जैसे तुम यहां
पे ऊपर जाओ ऊपर जाओ ऊपर जाओ हान हान
यूआरएल दे दिया उसके बाद तुम्हें यह वाली
चीज दे देनी है अगर तुम्हें दिख रहा होगा
हान t थ्रेड बढ़ा देना है थोड़ा सा
थ्रेडिंग कर देनी है थोड़ी सी बढ़ा देनी
है उसके बाद यहां पे
फर्स नफन फर्स करोगे तो यह चेक नहीं करेगा
कि वपस पे है या नहीं है उसके बाद नफन
एपीआई टोकन आपको दे देनी है ठीक है यह
वाली चीज़ करनी है मान लो डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन
हमने किया अ लेट्स सी इफ आई एम गेटिंग
द हां एी टोकन वाली मिल रही है ना हां
चलिए तो w स्न नफन
urls.com एजेंट तो यहां पे मैं - t भी
यूज़ कर लेता हूं थ्रेड बढ़ा देता हूं
थोड़ा सा मा फाइव है डिफॉल्ट तो हाइ फन t
करके इसको 30 कर देते हैं थ्रेड
को डिफॉल्ट कौन सा है भाई डिफॉल्ट पांच है
ना डिफॉल्ट पांच है ठीक है उसके बाद नवी
वर्वस मोड है आप चाहे तो कर सकते
[संगीत]
हैं ओके रैंडम यूजर एजेंट यहां पे हम
रैंडम यूजर एजेंट कर देते हैं हान एफन आर
यू ए तो यहां पे हान एफन आर यू ए थोड़ा सा
बचा रहेगा
अपना ठीक है और तो कुछ है नहीं उसके बाद
इनमेट का ऑप्शन है हान ई लगा दो इनमेट कर
लो भाई जो भी नरेट करना है सब यहां पर
इनमेट कर लो यहां पर जो भी इनन करनी है
बाकी फिलहाल नहीं कुछ करना है तो सब छोड़
दो अपने आप सब कुछ करेगा यह ठीक है यहां
पे यूजर नेम एंड पासवर्ड अगर आपको पता है
ब्रूट फोर्स करनी है तो हान यू देके यूजर
नेम डाल सकते हो या हान प देके पासवर्ड या
उसकी लिस्ट डाल सकते हो एंड ब्रूट फोर्स
कर सकते हो ठीक है ओके चलिए तो बस हो गया
ट्स इट एंड यहां पे आपको एंटर कर देना है
एंटर करोगे तो इधर डबलू पी स्कैन अपना काम
करना शुरू कर देगा कि जो भी चीजें हैं
आपको रिजल्ट जो है आपको लेबिलिटी जो है अ
दे देगा ये ठीक
है ठीक है चलिए तो हियर वी आर गेटिंग द
रिजल्ट्स तो हम सबसे पहले सीएमएस मैप पे आ
जाते हैं केसी ac.in पे इसका रिजल्ट आप
देख सकते
हैं जी हां तो यहां रिजल्ट में आपको देख
सकते हो टारगेट यहां पे आ चुका है पप 7.4
क्लाउड फ्लेयर से प्रोटेक्टेड है ये भैया
सीएमएस डिटेक्शन वर्डप्रेस हुई है बहुत
अच्छी बात है यहां पे एंड वपस वर्जन यहां
पे आपको मिल जा रहा है एग्जांपल से यहां
पे एग्जांपल्स यहां पे आ रहे है ठीक है जो
भी है यहां पे ये क्या आ रहा है
भाई हां यहां पे यह कर रहा है अपना काम तो
यहां पे जब रिजल्ट्स आ रहे हैं यहां पे तो
आपको देख रहे हो वर्डप्रेस थीम कौन सी है
यह बता रहा है यूजर नेम्स जो है इसने दे
दिया अनुराग एडमिन चंद्रशेखर विमल अनुराग
एडमिन ये सारे यहां पे थीम्स दे रहे हैं
ठीक है ये सारा क्या कर रहा है थीम्स दे
रहा है चंद्रशेखर अनुराग एडमिन विमल ये
सारा थीम्स दे रहा है अब यहां पे आ रहा है
एक्सएमएल आरपीसी सर्विसेस आर इनेबल्ड देखा
तो हमें पता चल गया कि एक्सएमए आरपीसी
सर्विस इनेबल्ड है यह कंप्लीट विनेबिलिटी
असेसमेंट एक तरह से यह भी आपको प्रोवाइड
करता है बहुत सारी रिजल्ट्स आपको चेक करके
दे देता है वेबसाइट वल्नरेबल टू एक्सएल
आरपीसी ब्रूट फोर्स वनबिल ब्रूट फोर्स
वलने बिलिटी यहां पे ये अफेक्टेड है बट से
ठीक है डिफॉल्ट वर्डप्रेस फाइल्स यहां पे
अब आ रही है ये सर्च कर रहा है डिफॉल्ट
वर्डप्रेस फाइल्स के लिए तो डिफॉल्ट
वर्डप्रेस फाइल्स के लिए रुक जाते हैं ठीक
है जस्ट लेटिंग इट कंप्लीट इदर डब्ल्यूपी
स्कैन ए मैप देखते हैं यहां पे ए मैप से
कुछ खास रिजल्ट यहां पे मिला नहीं है
सिंपल सा क्लाउड फेर प्रॉक्सी के थ्रू
होते हुए जा रहा है तो कुछ हमें यहां पे
मिल नहीं रहा फिलहाल आप एम के और भी चीजें
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं यहां हमें भाई मिल
चुकी है क्या हमें मिल चुकी है डब्ल्यूपी
स्कैन की रिजल्ट्स क्योंकि हमने एपीआई
टोकन डाला था तो ये लेबिलिटी भी फाइंड
करके दे रहा है डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन से तो अभी
देख लो डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन से वलने बिलिटी जब
फाइंड कर रहा है तो व्हाट इज हैपनिंग
लेट्स सी थ्री वलने बिलिटी
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
दूसरा है फाउंड बाय आरएस जनरेटर ठीक है
थ्री वनबिल फाइन पहला वलने बिलिटी क्या है
वर्डप्रेस 6.5.5 से लेस में जो भी जो भी
थीम्स है आपकी क्योंकि यह 6.5.4 है तो
इसमें कंट्रीब्यूटर प्लस स्टोर्ड एक्
एक्सेसेस इन एचटीएमएल एपीआई में आपको यहां
पे
मिलेगा डिटेल्स के लिए यहां पे इसकी लिंक
दी हुई है ओपन लिंक कीजिए आपको इस लिंक पे
आप लिंक को ओपन करेंगे यहां पे आपको इसकी
डिटेल्स जो है मिल जाएगी वपस डज नॉट
प्रॉपर्ली एस्केप यूआरएल एटिबल एपीआई
अलांग हाई प्रिविलेज यूजर्स टू परफॉर्म
स्टोर्ड क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग याद
रखिएगा हाई प्रिविलेज यूजर्स नहीं कर सकते
हैं लो प्रिविलेज या जनरल यूजर्स इस पे यह
नहीं कर सकते थे बट स्टिल बिकॉज दिस वाज
लेबिलिटी तो यहां पे मेंशन है उसी तरीके
से स्टोर्ड एक्सेसेस यहां पे फिर से यहां
पे पाथ ट्राइवर्स इन टेंप्लेट पाट ब्लॉक
यहां पे आ रहा है ठीक है यह लेबिलिटी थी
उसके बाद कोई और वलने बिलिटी तो नहीं दिख
रही है एक वलने बिलिटी यहां मिली है किसम
मिली है भैया यहां पे सीएफएस सीएफ से
कंडीशनल फील्ड्स में यहां पे मिली है एंड
ये मिली है आपके प्लगिंस के अंदर में cf7
कंडीशनल वल्स में तो यहां पे क्या मिला
भैया क्रॉस साइट रिक्वेस्ट फॉर जरी टू
प्लगइन सेटिंग रिसेट ठीक है भैया एक ये
मिली है आपकी लेबिलिटी इसको आप अगर
एक्सप्लोइट करना चाहते हैं तो आप इसकी
एक्सप्लोइट की जो रेफरेंसेस है इस रेफरेंस
को यूज करके एक्सप्लोइट करेंगे ठीक है
जैसे कि यहां पे मान लो डब्ल्यूपी स्कन का
अपना रेफरेंस है आप रेफरेंस पे जाएंगे
यहां पे तो यहां पे इसकी भी डिटेल आपको आ
जाएगी जो भी डिटेल वगैरह है ये आ जाएगी
आपको रेफरेंस में आपको यहां पे मिल जाएगा
जैसे कि यह रेफरेंस है यहां पे ये सीवी है
यहां पे जो सीवी रजिस्टर हुई है तो यहां
पे वड फ्रेंस की तरफ से आपको रेफरेंस
मिलेगा तो यहां पे क्या है रेफरेंस में
भैया कंडीशनल फील्स फॉर कांटेक्ट फॉर्म से
कांटेक्ट फॉर्म सेन का लेस दन 2.4.13
वर्जन था उसमें क्रॉस साइट रिक्वेस्ट फजरी
हो रही थी प्लग इन सेटिंग रिक्वेस्ट रिसेट
सेटिंग को रिसेट कर दिया जा रहा था
हालांकि इसका ज्यादा इंपैक्ट इंपैक्टफुल
नहीं है यह लाइक सीबीएसएस स्कोर इसका काफी
कम है 4.3 है तो मतलब ठीक है मतलब बहुत
हाई क्रिटिकल वनरे बिलिटी नहीं है इट्स
मीडियम ठीक है तो यहां पे आपको पूरा डिटेल
इसके बारे में दिया गया रहेगा जो भी चीजें
हैं यहां पे रेफरेंस यहां पे एंड यहां पे
पूरा डिटेल दिया हुआ है कौन सा न है क्या
है पैस्ड हां भाई पैच हो चुकी है तो
लेटस्ट पैच वर्जन
2.4.14 में इसको पैच कर दिया गया था इसके
बाद यह सीवी है यहां पे इसके रिगार्डिंग
जो सीवी हुई है तो यह सीवी आपको यहां मिल
जाएगी एंड इसके अलग-अलग रेफरेंसेस मिल
जाएंगे जिस पर आप आके चेक आउट कर सकते हो
कि भैया इसको कैसे एक्सप्लोइट किया जा
सकता है ठीक है उसके बाद नीचे आते हैं
यहां पे हां नीचे आते हैं और भी कोई
लेबिलिटी अगर मिल जाए तो ऐसा कुछ है नहीं
सिंपल सा
हां कुछ खास लेबिलिटी यहां पर कुछ है नहीं
ठीक है बैकअप वगैरह कुछ है नहीं यहां पर
तो ट्स इट खत्म तो यह हमारा यहां पर हमें
डब्ल्यूपी स्कन ने हमें खोज के निकाल के
दे दिया है अब हम यहां पर जो हमारा टारगेट
दिया था हमने इस टारगेट में हम यहां पर
थोड़ा सा चेंज करते हैं एंड वी आर गोइंग
टू प्रोवाइड अ टारगेट ट इज
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग एंड यह टारगेट हमारा
गवर्नमेंट वाला टारगेट है तो गवर्नमेंट
टारगेट को हम एक बार ट्राई आउट कर ही लेते
हैं क्या ही जाता है हमारा
टा
टा चलिए तो हमने ये कर लिया यहां पे टोकन
देके हमने फिर से एंटर करते हैं देखते हैं
टारगेट चेंज करते हैं व्ट इज गोइंग टू
हैपन नाउ लेट्स वी हैव अ टारगेट आड
n.n. देखते हैं कुछ मिलता है कि नहीं एंड
यहां पे हमारा यह रिक्वेस्ट चल रहा है
यहां पे कुछ कुछ चीजें यहां पे मिल रही है
यहां पर डिफॉल्ट वर्डप्रेस फाइल्स यहां पर
मिल रही है जो डिफॉल्ट फाइल्स है वो मिल
गई है तो प ओके अपलोड मिली है अपलोड
लाइसेंस और कुछ खास तो मिला नहीं हमें ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं चल रहा है य कुछ एर आई है
इसको इग्नोर कर दीजिएगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है हा जी तो यहां हमें रिजल्ट मिल रहा है
क्या आ रहा है भाई रोटी के अंदर क्या क्या
है अरे वाह लगन प रजिस्टर पीएपी ट्रैक बैक
ठीक है डब्ल्यूपी इंक्लूड्स छिपा हुआ है
डब्लू पी इंक्लूड्स क्यों छिपा हुआ है
क्यों छुपाया हुआ डब्ल्यूपी इंक्लूड्स
हा डब् इंक्लूड्स क्यों छिपाया हुआ
है हम तो देखेंगे डब्लू बी हान इन
इंक्लूड्स क्यों छुपाया
भाई
अच्छा हम फॉर बिडेन है ये कोई बात नहीं
यार छिपा लिया है तो कोई बात नहीं
चलेगा क्या ये क्या ही हो जाएगा यार छिपा
लो कोई बात नहीं चलो तो यहां पे robot.txt
हमें एक्सएमए आरपीसी टू बी इनेबल्ड अच्छी
बात है डायरेक्ट एक्सेस मैंने बताया था कि
एक्स में है इनेबल तो है भैया एंड यहां पे
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग हो रही है भैया एंड इधर
अपना काम हो रहा है तो इधर इधर भी हमें
देखने को हमें पता चल जाएगा कि हमें इसमें
कोई लेबिलिटी है या नहीं है वी विल फाइंड
आउट कि कोई वल्नरेबल है कि नहीं है ठीक है
तो इस तरीके से यू कैन फाइंड अ कंप्लीट
वल्नरेबल अ एंड उसका एक रिपोर्ट तैयार आप
कर सकते हैं रिपोर्ट तैयार करके आप वोह
सामने वाले क्लाइंट को दे सकते हैं सबसे
पहली बात प्लगिंस एंड थीम्स को इग्नोर
नहीं करना है प्लगिंस एंड थीम्स वल्नरेबल
प्लगिंस एंड वल्नरेबल थीम्स इनमें ही
वल्नरेबल होती है एक्सप्लोइटेबल वल्नरेबल
होती है जो आपको ट्राई आउट करना है अब
यहां पे मैं आपको अब ले चलता हूं एक
एमएसएफ कंसोल पे मेटा
एक्सप्लोइट फ्रेमवर्क आपको ओपन करता हूं
एंड मेटा स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क प थोड़ा आपको
लेकर चलता हूं कि वहां भी आप कैसे फाइंड
आउट कर सकते हैं
चलिए याद रखिएगा पहले मेटा स्प्ड
फ्रेमवर्क एमएसएफ अपडेट से अपडेट होती थी
अब यह डिप्रेशिएट हो चुकी है लेटेस्ट आपके
रि सॉरी लेटेस्ट रिलीज में आपके काली के
तो आपको अगर अपडेट अपडेट करना है तो पट
अपडेट कर लीजिएगा पहली तो
पहले तो पट अपडेट कर लीजिएगा उसके बाद आप
एप्ट इंस्टॉल मेटा एक्सप्लोइट फ्रेम वर्क
करके इसको अपडेट अपडेट जो भी करना है कर
लीजिएगा ठीक है तो मैं एमएसएफ कंसोल ओपन
कर लेता
हूं फर्स्ट ऑफ ल लेट्स ओपन
कंसोल हां जी हां जी हां जी हां जी प्लीज
अमन प्लीज आप बता दीजिए शमीम विल नोट ट
ओके
सर वैसे आप कितना कमाते हो अरे लाखों में
कमा रहा हूं मैं क्या दिक्कत है बहुत
कमाता हूं यार बहुत कमाता
हूं ठीक
है चलो ठीक है आ जाओ पता नहीं यार मेरे
मेरे अर्निंग से क्या
मतलब लेना देना इनको सीख लो यार सीख लो
इधर सीखो तुम भी कमाओगे यार सीख लो हैव द
स्किल्स मनी विल फ्लो ठीक है अब यहां पर
आके हमें सर्च करना सर्च क्या सर्च करना
है भाई मैं तो भूल गया सर्च हमें अब सर्च
करना है एक ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल स्कैनिंग
मॉड्यूल टाइप अ ऑक्जिलियम
करना है वर्डप्रेस का एक ऑक्जिलियम सर्च
करना है एक्सएमए आरपीसी से वर्डप्रेस का
पहले सर्च कर लेते हैं तो हमें जितने भी
रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे सब वर्डप्रेस से रिलेटेड
जनरली मिलेंगे आपको तो मोस्टली वर्डप्रेस
के ही आपको मिलेंगे सारे
ऑक्जिराने तो हमें एक्सएमए से रिलेटेड
चाहिए तो वी विल जस्ट चेंज इट अ लिटिल बिट
एकए आरपीसी एंटर करेंगे अच्छा गलती लिख
दिया हमने एक्सएमए है एकए आरपीसी तो हमें
तीन रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं पहला क्या है
स्कैनर वर्डप्रेस घोस्ट स्कैनर है क्या है
भैया यह वर्डप्रेस एक्सएमए आरपीसी घोस्ट
वनबिल स्कैनर ठीक है एक्सए आरपीसी गोज
वल्नरेबल बताएगा भैया कि वल्नरेबल है क्या
है यहां पे एक है अ h वपस xmlrpc.php
तो सिस्टम ड मल्टी कॉल क्रेडेंशियल
कलेक्टर्स यहां पे इसका आप यूज कर सकते
हैं एंड यहां पे वर्डप्रेस एक्सएमए आरपीसी
डॉस तो यहां पे ये डॉस अटैक के लिए यूज हो
रहा है तो आप इसको ऑक्सल को आप यूज कर
लीजिएगा एज अ चलो मैं इसको एज अ होमवर्क
आपको दे देता हूं इससे ज्यादा आपको चलो
हिंट थोड़ा और दे देता हूं मैं आपको ठीक
है थोड़ा और हिंट दे देता हूं लेकिन आप
सिंपल सा है मेटा स्पॉइल यूज करना बहुत
इजी होता है यू सीधा यूज ऑक्सल कीजिएगा
एंड जो भी ऑक्सल का है वो दे दीजिएगा पूरा
पाथ एंड देन आप शो ऑप्शंस करके उसके जो भी
ऑप्शन सेट करने हैं वो दे देख लीजिएगा शो
एक्शंस करके आप एक्शन सेट कर सकते हैं अगर
है कोई तो या शो इंफो करके आप पूरी की
पूरी इंफो देख सकते हैं उस पर्टिकुलर
मॉड्यूस का ठीक है चलिए मैं आपको थोड़ा सा
एग्जांपल हल्का सेट देता हूं जैसे मुझे
मान लो
कि घोस्ट स्कैनर यूज करना है ये वाला तो
मैं क्या करूंगा यूज ऑक्सल स्कैनर एटीटीपी
अ वर्डप्रेस
घोस्ट स्कैनर ठीक है तो मैंने इसको यूज
किया अब ये हम इस पर्टिकुलर ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल
में आ चुके हैं अब हम करेंगे क्या यहां पे
फो तो यहां पे इस पर्टिकुलर मॉड्यूल की
पूरी इंफो आ जाएगी इंफॉर्मेशन वर्डप्रेस
घोस्ट वल बिलिटी स्कैनर किसने इसको किसके
कौन इसका राइटर है जो भी है और यहां पे
क्या-क्या इसके ऑप्शंस यहां पे क्या-क्या
है ठीक है तो ये ऑप्शंस आप देख सकते हैं
लाइक हियर हियर आर ऑप्शंस डिफरेंट काइंड
ऑफ ऑप्शंस डिस्क्रिप्शन क्या है दिस
मॉड्यूल कैन बी यूज टू डिटरमाइंड होस्ट्स
वल्नरेबल टू होस्ट वल्नरेबल वाया कॉल्ड टू
द वर्डप्रेस एक्सएमएल आरपीसी इंटरफेस इफ द
टारगेट इज वल्नरेबल
सिस्टम विल सेक फॉल्ट एंड रिटर्न अ सवर
एरर ठीक है तो चलिए ये आप समझ में आ गया
इस तरीके से हमें यहां पे इस तरीके से हम
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं तो अब हमें क्या
करना है यहां पे शो ऑप्शंस करने
है शो ऑप्शंस में क्या-क्या सेट करने है
भैया एक तो यहां पे आर होस्ट सेट करनी है
आर पोर्ट सेट करनी है एंड ठीक है टारगेट
यूआई स्लश ही रहेगा हमारा मेन वेबसाइट मेन
डोमेन के लिए हमारा स्लैश ही रहेगा टारगेट
वेबसाइट तो हां थ्रेड वन है टू है जो भी
है वो सेट कर लीजिए तो सेट आर होस्ट कर
लेते हैं सेट आर होस्ट तो हम कोई सा भी
होस्ट ले लेते लाइक काइंड
ऑफ एक हमें मिली थी ना कोई
होस्ट कौन सा मिला था यार डबल डब्लू स्कैन
करके हमने कुछ किया था ना नहीं नहीं ए मैप
प हमने कुछ किया
था हा यह किया था ना यह वाली यह वाली
होस्ट मिली थी
हमें ये क्या हो रहा है यार हा यह वाली
होस्ट है हमारी आई डोंट नो दिस इज रीचे बल
और नॉट एक बार देख लेते हैं रीचे बल है भी
कि नहीं यार पिंग एंड दिस वन हां पिंग हो
रहा है रीचे बल है यह डायरेक्ट आईपी
एक्सेस अलाउड है
क्या अ नहीं डायरेक्ट क्लाउड फ्लेर अच्छा
यह क्लाउड फेर की आईपी है ओके गाइ स दिस
इज अ क्लाउड फेर आईपी तो वैसे भी कोई काम
का नहीं है तो हम सिंपल होस्ट को
डायरेक्टली होस्ट को एंटर करते हैं कोई
दिक्कत कोई प्रॉब्लम वाली बात नहीं होनी
चाहिए ठीक है सो वी आर जस्ट गोइंग टू एंटर
द होस्ट तो हम यहां पे होस्ट कर लेते हैं
कौन सा भई यह वाला कर लेते हैं आईआरपी
नीडा आईआरपी नीडा पीडा जो भी है इसको ही
ट्राई आउट कर लेते हैं क्या जाता है हमारा
तो हम यहां पे होस्ट डाल देते हैं .
n.n. तो हमने होस्ट डाल दिया एंड यहां पे
हमने आर होस्ट करके यहां पे एंटर कर देते
हैं ठीक है तो ये हमारा सेट हो गया अब
यहां पे पोर्ट डालना है तो सेट आर पोर्ट
सेट या सेट जी आप यूज कर सकते हैं ग्लोबली
आपको अगर कुछ सेट करना है तो एंड यहां पे
हम पोर्ट डाल देते हैं मान लो 443 डाल दो
या 808 डाल दो दो तो हम 443 पे चेक कर
लेते हैं 443 चेक कर लेते हैं कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है तो यहां पे शो ऑप्शंस करेंगे आपके
सारे ऑप्शंस यहां पे आ चुके रहेंगे एंड
यहां पे अगर यह सही से काम करेगा तो गुड
यहां रन पे क्लिक करेंगे एंटर करेंगे कुछ
अगर मिला तो तो यह क्या आ रहा है दिस
साइट्स लुक्स लाइक नो वर्डप्रेस ब्लॉग यह
कौन सी बात है हट ऐसा नहीं है नहीं है
मतलब यह सही से काम नहीं कर रहा एक काम
करते हैं सेट डब्ल्यूपी चेक डिसेबल कर
देते हैं फॉल्स कर देते हैं एंड देन रन
करते
हैं एक्सएल इंटरफेस इज नॉट इनेबल चलिए ये
गलत बता रहा है यानी कि ये गलत बता रहा है
इसके मॉड्यूस में प्रॉब्लम है ये जो
मॉड्यूस है पर्टिकुलर इनमें प्रॉब्लम्स है
इसलिए गलत बता रहा है ठीक है बाकी जो
मॉड्यूस है उसको भी ट्राई आउट कर लीजिएगा
लाइक जो यह मॉड्यूस मैंने आपको यहां पे
दिखाए
हैं बैक अ वही जो अपन ने देखा था अभी
थोड़ी देर पहले कहां गया ये वाला तो बाकी
मॉड्यूस को एक बार ट्राई आउट कीजिएगा
अलग-अलग टारगेट्स के लिए ठीक है मल्टी कॉल
क्रेडेंशियल वाली एक्सएमएल डॉस के लिए एंड
ब्रूट फोर्स के लिए तो ब्रूट फोर्स हो गया
ये ये स्कैनर हो गया ये डॉस अटैक के लिए
हो गया ये कैडेंस के लिए हो गया ठीक है तो
ब्रूट फोर्स करके ये भी ट्राई करके एक बार
देख लीजिएगा एज अ टास्क आप एक बार ट्राई
कीजिएगा जितना ट्राई कीजिएगा उतना बेनिफिट
है आपके लिए ठीक है भैया मैं बस इतना ही
बोलता हूं जितनी प्रैक्टिस करोगे उतना
आपको मजा आएगा किसी भी पर्टिकुलर वलने
बिलिटी के अंदर ठीक है तो हमने यहां पे
कुछ ओके यहां पे कुछ लेबिलिटी नहीं मिली
हमें इस वेबसाइट में क्या बात है यार ये
गवर्नमेंट वेबसाइट है तो ठीक है इन्होंने
करा लिया होगा कुछ कुछ थोड़ा बहुत चीजें
थोड़ी बहुत चीजें बच गई
है बट हमें कोई वनबिल ऐसी कोई क्रिटिकल
वनबिल नहीं मिली है इस पे दैट्ची
इंप्रेसिव तो नट गेट एनी अटी राइट तो हमें
एक बंदे ने किसी ने एक वेबसाइट दी थी कौन
सी वेबसाइट दी थी भाई एक बार
दिखाओ कहां गया उसका वेबसाइट क्या है अशा
वेटेक आईटी सोलूशंस क्या है भाई य प्रमोशन
करवा रहे हो क्या इसी में अशा वेब टेक
आईटी सॉल्यूशन क्या सॉल्यूशन है भाई क्या
सॉल्यूशन देते हो
खतरनाक वेबसाइट है ये
तो अरे बाप रे गजब वेबसाइट बनाई है भाई
आशा वेब
टेक अच्छा यह एक्सपायर हो गया क्या यह ठीक
है हां जी इनकी वेबसाइट
है क्या सर्विसेस है भाई ग्राफिक्स
वेबसाइट डेवलपमेंट क्या बात है चलिए तो
यहां पे ये वर्डप्रेस प है वेबसाइट ये एक
बार वी कैन जस्ट गव इट ट्राई दिस वेबसाइट
इज ऑन वर्डप्रेस राइट सो सिंपल सा हम एक
बार देख लेते हैं एक्सल आरपीसी पीएपी
इनेबल्ड है कि नहीं है पहले तो पोस्ट
रिक्वेस्ट ओनली हां जी इनेबल्ड है यह तो
यह अच्छी बात है अगर पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट है
तो इनेबल्ड है तो लेट्स सी गिव इट ट्राई ए
सिंपल एट ठीक है तो यहां पर हमने दे दिया
एक्सम
आरपीसी इसको हम यहां पर पकड़ लेते हैं
यहां पर कुछ मिला क्या भाई हमें फिनिश हो
गई पूरी की पूरी बट हमें लेंथ में कुछ
चेंजेज मिला क्या कुछ नहीं मिला कुछ खास
तो हम कुछ यहां पर ब्रूट फोर्स में मिला
नहीं तो इसको भगाओ यहां पर प्रॉक्सी प
चलते इंटरसेप्ट ऑन कर लेते हैं यहां चलके
इसको पकड़ लेते हैं तो हमने एक्स आरपीसी य
पर पकड़ लिया यहां
पर प पकड़ लिया पकड़ लिया को पकड़ लिया
पकड़ लिया क्यों निकल रहा है मेरे मुंह से
यार यह वीडियोस देखने का यह सब नतीजा है
यह य पर ऐसे वीडियोस आते हैं ना
भाई व पकड़
लिया ओ माय गॉड चलो ठीक
है आप लोग समझ पा रहे हो मैं क्या बोल रहा
हूं अभी कुछ दिन पहले मैंने वीडियो देखी
थी बहुत पॉपुलर यूट्यूब लड़ते रहते हैं एक
दूसरे
में पकड़ लिया पकड़ लिया यह सब य एक एक
बोल चलो ठीक है तो यहां पर
सेंड सर जी सीधा ध्रु राठी को सपोर्ट करते
हैं अरे ऐसा कुछ नहीं है भाई मैं किसी को
सपोर्ट किसी को अपोज नहीं करता भाई यह
मैंने वो तो मेरे को उसका बोलने का तरीका
यह थोड़ा हंसी आया था मतलब जब बोला था तो
काफी हंसी आई थी इसलिए मैंने बोला आई डोंट
सपोर्ट एनी वन एनीबडी आई सपोर्ट फनि
अकेडमी डिफन साइबर सिक्योरिटी को सपोर्ट
करता हूं मैं बाकी किसी को नहीं करता हूं
ठीक है तो यहां पे सेंड टू रिपीटर प क्लिक
कर देते हैं इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ कर देते हैं ठीक
है
भैया कोई बात नहीं यार अब यहां पे हम गो प
क्लिक करेंगे तो यह गो होगा नहीं वही है
चेंज रिक्वेस्ट मेथड प क्लिक कर देते हैं
गो पे अब गो होगा ये तो गो गो अब गो गो गो
गो होने लगा यहां पे तो अगेन यही वही चीज
है भाई सेम पकड़ के ले
आओ यहां पे कॉपी मारा यहां पे सिस्टम
लिस्ट
मेथड हां जी तो यहां पे सारी सिस्टम लिस्ट
मेथड है यहां पे एंड यहां पे हमारा डेमो
डॉट से हेलो भी है तो लेट्स
सी डेमो डॉट से हेलो
हेलो भैया हेलो सर्वर हेलो हेलो कर दिया
इसने अच्छी बात है प्रीवियस रिक्वेस्ट पर
चल जाते हैं एंड य मल्टी कॉल तो है ही
सिस्टम ठीक है यह सब चीजें तो है ही पिंग
बैक पिंग पिंग बैक पिंग पिंग बैक पिंग तो
पिंग बैक पिंग वाले भैया को उठा लेते एक
बार यहां से कहां गए पिंग बैक पिंग हां जी
यह रहे हमारे पिंग बैक पिंग तो इन पिंग
बैक पिंग को उठा लेते हैं एंड यहां पर एक
बार चेक बैक चेक कर लेते हैं
अगेन ठीक है पिंग बैक पिंग पे आ गए यहां
पे एंड एंड एंड एंड एंड लेट्स लोड लेट्स
क्रिएट क्रिएट आजा
भाई आजा भाई कॉपी कर
ले एंड यर टिक टक टिक टक टिक टक तो हमने
दे दिया य पे एंड यहां यूआरएल भैया देनी
है तो यूआरएल तो भैया हमारी यह यूआरएल है
हमारी आसा
वेबसाइट ठीक है तो हमने एक यूआरएल भी दे
दिया चलो
हां जी तो वी हैव गिवन द यूआरएल एंड नाउ
लेट्स क्लिक ऑन ओके गो गो गो नाउ लेट्स
चेक आउट चेक चेक चेक तो वी डोंट गेट यहां
प कुछ मिला नहीं हमें कोई बात नहीं यार
कोई बात नहीं इतना यार टेंशन का को लेना
है गो पे क्लिक करते हैं गो पे क्लिक करते
हैं कोई बात नहीं यार नॉट नॉट नॉट नॉट नॉट
तो एक बार आप एक बार चेक कर लेते इनकी
वेबसाइट में यहां पे डब्ल्यूपी जसन वाली
चीज है डब् प जसन स्ड प स् v2 स् यूजर्स
लेट्स सी अरे इनके पास भी यूजर्स है आई आई
ए शान है क्या कुछ यूजर भाई आईटी आशा वेब
टेक सोल्यूशन वाले बताओ यार यहां पे यह
यूजर है क्या आई आईए शन करके बताइए आप ही
बताइए भाई आशा वेटेक वाले आईए
शान है आशा वेब टेक
अच्छा हां तो यहां पर ये एक नरेट और सुपर
एडमिन एडमिन का यूजर है व है ना एडमिन
मतलब एडमिन वाला यूजर है यह है ना क्योंकि
सुपर एडमिन ट्रू आ रहा य पर यह राइट
मार्केटिंग टेक सर्विस बताइए मतलब एडमिन
है वह यह वाली यूजर नेम यस एडमिन है
ना तो यस यस यस समझ गया मैं डब्ल्यूपी
एडमिन है तो एडमिन का यहां पर यूजर नेम य
पर मिल चुका है य पर बेसिकली एंड यहां पर
मैं अगर डब्ल्यूपी हान एडमिन कर
दूं तो यहां पे इनका आएगा यहां पे अगर मैं
एडमिन यूजर के लिए लॉगइन करता हूं तो वी
विल सी द यूजरनेम एडमिन इज नॉट रजिस्टर ऑन
इन साइट तो यूजर नेम एडमिन रजिस्टर्ड नहीं
है इस पे लेकिन मैं अगर आईए शान करूं आईए
शान एंड यहां पे कुछ भी डालूं तो ये
रजिस्टर्ड होगा ये आएगा कि यूजर नेम द
पासवर्ड इनकरेक्ट फॉर आईए शान इज इनकरेक्ट
तो यहां पे ये इनकरेक्ट आ रहा है मतलब आईए
शान एक यूजर तो भैया है ये कंफर्म हो चुका
है तो अब इसे फिर रूट फोर्स वगैरह ट्राई
आउट मार सकते हैं वी कैन जस्ट गिव इट अ
ट्राई आउट यहां पे एक और है यहां
पे हां ठीक है आईए शन है है
ना अब इसको तुम लाइक उसमें डाल दो
डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन में डाल दो और इसको चला
दो डब्ल्यूपी स्कन में डाल के वो आपकी
मर्जी है डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन में डाल के चला
दो ट कंपलीटली योर
विश यह रही डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन डब्ल्यूपी
स्कैन एंड यहां पर हम यूआरएल प्रोवाइड कर
देते
हैं अवेलेबिलिटीज वगैरह ये सब कुछ यहां पे
पता चल जाएगा अगर कुछ है तो यहां पे आ
जाएगी ठीक
है हां लेट्स
सी पासवर्ड 25 कैरेक्टर्स का है तो तो
क्या हो गया मैं मैं थोड़ी ना पागल हूं कि
25 कैरेक्टर्स के पासवर्ड को ब्रूट फोर्स
करने
चलूंगा इतना इतना टाइम नहीं है
भाई चलो अच्छी बात है आरपीसी इनेबल्ड है
अच्छी बात है यहां पे डायरेक्ट डब्ल्यूपी
क्रॉन सीम्स टू बी इनेबल्ड अ डब्लू पी
क्रॉन भी नेब है क्या बात है
यार डब्लू पी क्रॉन से डीडी वगर ट्राई आउट
कर सकते हो आप डीस इसका रेफरेंस है पढ़
सकते
आप ठीक
है लेट्स
सी व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग वट
ट ना ना ना
ना नहीं है भाई नहीं
है वजन डिटेक्ट नहीं हो रहा ठीक है कोई
बात
नहीं रेटिंग ऑल प्लग
इनस ठीक कुछ खास यहां पर है नहीं एलिमेंटर
यूज करते हो एलिमेंटर यूज किया क्या भाई
एलिमेंटर प्लगइन यूज किया
क्या आई थिंक सो किया होगा शायद उसकी
डिटेल आ रही है
ठीक है यूज किया है हां ठीक है ट व कॉमर्स
यूज कर रहे हैं य एलिमेंटरी यूज कर रहे
कोई ऐसी कुछ खास लेबिलिटी है नहीं थोड़ी
बहुत लाइक नॉर्मल सी वो है सिंपल सा वो है
ठीक है ना तो ये प्लगिंस की डिटेल्स है तो
इस तरीके से आप नमरे वगैरह कर सकते हो
इसके जो भी नरेशन है जो भी चीजें कर सकते
हो यहां पे ये 99 पर प रुक जाता है थोड़ा
इसके बाद काफी टाइम लेता है इसको मैं
क्लोज कर देता हूं कोई बंदे कोई टेंशन
नहीं है ठीक है तो ये एक्सएल आरपीसी अब
देखो एक्सएमएल आरपीसी को आप अलग अलग
वेबसाइट के लिए टारगेट के लिए डोमेन के
लिए अलग-अलग लिस्ट ऑफ मेथड्स जो दिए गए
हैं उससे ट्राई करके एंड टाइम देना होगा
ब्रूट फोर्स करना है डॉज करना है देखना है
कि वेबसाइट रेस्पों करना बंद करी है कि
नहीं काम कर रही है कि नहीं यू हैव टू
जस्ट गिव इट अ ट्राई अगर हो रहा है तो भाई
वो वल्नरेबल है पर्टिकुलर नहीं हो रहा है
तो वल्नरेबल नहीं है बस तो आपको दिखाना
पड़ेगा पहले क्या था कि एक्सएमएल आरपीसी
इनेबल्ड है बस इतना बोल दिया दिखा दिया कि
भैया हो रहा है यहां पे हो गया इतना में
काम हो जाता था अब आप वहां प इंपैक्ट शो
करना पड़ेगा कि भैया देखो मैंने यहां पर
ब्रूट फोर्स करा है मैंने यह डॉस किया
एप्लीकेशन लेवल डॉस टैक किया यह किया वो
किया है एंड ये हो रहा है तो आपको वो चीज
करनी पड़ेगी ठीक है समझ में आ रहा
है हेलो वसंत लोजन दिस इज ऑल द प्रैक्टिस
एंड
प्रैक्टिस प्रैक्टिस एंड प्रैक्टिस एपीआई
की मिली है अगर आपको कहीं पे तो आपको अगर
यह नहीं पता चल पा कि वो एपीआई की किस चीज
की है क्या है तो फिर इसका मतलब आपका पूरा
अभी प्रैक्टिस नहीं हुआ है पहली बात तो
एपीआई की मिलेगी अगर आपको तो उस एपीआई की
का जो एक्सेस लेवल है वह आप अटेंड कर पा
रहे हो कि नहीं उसको आप दिखा पा रहे हो कि
नहीं दिखा पा रहे हो वोह आपको करना है पता
करना है कि भाई ये किस टाइप का अब
एडब्ल्यू केपी है तो एडब्ल्यू एस का आपको
अगर कोई की मिला है कोई पर्टिकुलर सीक्रेट
या एक्सेस की मिला है तो वो आपका एडब्ल्यू
एस का होगा तो वहां से तो पता चल जाता है
सिंपल सा फंडा है तो आप उस पर्टिकुलर
एप्लीकेशन के लिए उसको ट्राई आउट करोगे ए
देन अगर आप इंपैक्ट दिखा पाते हो तो
रिपोर्ट करोगे नहीं तो नहीं करोगे बस
सिंपल सा फंडा है नहीं तो कई बार नॉट
एप्लीकेबल लिख देते गुस्से में आके वो
लो दश ज्योति दर्श जोशी मैं रिप्लाई नहीं
करता अरे नहीं यार सर कैसे पता लगेगा कि
हनी पॉट है हनी पॉट होने के बहुत सारे
तरीके हैं बहुत सारे चेक मार्क्स है जो आप
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं कोई वेबसाइट है अगर
कोई वेबसाइट है बहुत इजी टू पेनिट्रेट
आपकी लग रही है एंड यू आर गोइंग एंड यू आर
गेटिंग अ लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स आउट ऑफ डूइंग
नथिंग मतलब थोड़ी बहुत चीजें करके आपको
बहुत चीजें मिल रही है कुछ ना कुछ वहां पे
फिर गड़बड़ है ऐसी वेबसाइट से आपको बच के
रहना है ऐसी वेबसाइट प आपको ज्यादा टाइम
नहीं देना है आप खुद सोचो ना यार आप एक एक
चेन आपको मिलते जा रही है इसका मतलब वहां
पर गड़बड़ है सिंपल सा फंडा है तो ये आपको
समझना है थोड़ा सा राइट
चलिए तो यह तो हमने कर
लिया ऐसे देरर मल्टीपल तरीके जिससे आप पता
कर सकते हो ठीक है इसको हम कर देते हैं
बंद कर देते हैं ठीक है चलिए अब मुझे आप
लोग बताइए आप लोग से पूछता हूं मैं आप
सबसे पूछता हूं ठीक है एवरीवन टेल मी
देखते हैं भाई कौन क्या बताता है याद
रखिएगा दिमाग लगा के
बताइएगा मान लो मेरे पास एक वर्डप्रेस
वेबसाइट
है कल और आज में जो भी आपने सीखा उसके
बेसिस पर बताओ वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट है मुझे
उस पर पेन टेस्ट करनी है तो आप क्या क्या
चीजें करोगे वह बताते जाओ एक एक करके
जितने भी लोग हैं सब बताइए क्याक चीज आप
उस पर करोगे चलिए बताइए
यस एसएस आरफी का यूज कर सकते हो बिल्कुल
हम ठीक
है बताइए सभी लोग बताइए
सीएमएस डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन सभी लोग बताइए
ताकि बाकी लोग भी देखे बाकी लोग देखिए
बाकी लोग इसको
देखिए डब्ल्यूपी कंटेंट अपलोड्स ठीक है वो
भी सही
है डब्ल्यूपी जेसन डब्ल्यूपी यूजर्स ठीक
है वजन लाइजर ठीक है सबसे पहले डब्ल्यूपी
स्कन टू यूज करेंगे वल्नरेबल प्लग ठीक है
डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन करूंगा एक्सएमएल आरपीसी
फाइंड करूंगा डब्ल्यूपी ओके जीरो
डायरेक्टरीज ठीक
है
ओके
ओके अच्छा देखते हैं यहां पे डैम वल्नरेबल
है कि नहीं ठीक है
बताइए लेट्स
से डीवीडब्ल्यू
पी अ यहां पे अवेलेबल तो है तो एक काम आप
लोग कीजिएगा गाइस डू वन थिंग एक काम आप
लोग कीजिएगा ठीक है आप लोग यह वाली जो चीज
है डीवीडब्ल्यू प ठीक है इसको आप लोग यूज
कीजिएगा ठीक है डैम वल्नरेबल वर्डप्रेस
एंड इसपे टेस्टिंग कीजिएगा ठीक है इस पे
टेस्टिंग कीजिएगा आप लोग प्रैक्टिस करने
के लिए इसको इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा इंस्टॉल
करने का तरीका सीधा यहां पे बता हुआ है
बताया हुआ है डॉकर आप इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा
डॉकर के थ्रू आप डायरेक्टली इसको एक्सेस
कर सकते हैं गेट क्लोन करना है इसके अंदर
जाना है डॉकर कंपोज करके इसको बिल्ड कर
लेना है एंड देन इसको आपको डॉकर से रन कर
लेना है ठीक है एंड इंस्टॉल कर लेनी है
ठीक है यूसेज क्या है डॉकर कंपोज डब्ल्यू
बीडी एंड यहां पे डाउन यहां पे करके आपको
यूसेज आपको कर लेनी है शल आपको लाना है तो
शल इस तरीके से ला सकते हैं एंड इंटरफेस
जो है आपको यहां पे आपके लोकल होस्ट पे जो
है इंटरफेस में मिल जाएगी कौन सी लोकल
होस्ट पे जैसे 227 127 001 कॉलन एंड इस
पोर्ट पे 3133 7 पे आपको इसका पैनल मिल
जाएगा एडमिन पैनल आपको इस पे मिल जाएगा
एंड इसको आपको पीएचपी माय एडमिन मिल जाएगी
क्रीडेंस क्या है आपके एसक्यूएल के लिए
माय एसक्यूएल के लिए रूट एंड पासवर्ड
रहेगा वर्डप्रेस के लिए एडमिन एंड एडमिन
रहेगा ठीक है तो आप क्या कीजिएगा इसमें
कौन-कौन सा अ प्लगइन डाला गया है आप देख
लीजिए यहां पे इनफा डब्ल्यूपी क्लाइंट ये
सारे वल्नरेबल प्लगिंस इसमें डाले गए हैं
ठीक है यहां पे अदर्स में क्या-क्या है
डायरेक्टरी स्टिंग है डिस्प्ले एरर्स है
info.php है डड एएल है एमार पीप है सर्च
रिप्लेस डीवी है क्रॉस डोमेन है इसमें और
भी चीज आने की लिख रखा इन्होंने बा नहीं
आया बात कोई बात नहीं खत्म कहानी आप इतना
इस पर प्रैक्टिस कर लीजिएगा ठीक है दिस इज
अ वेरी गुड थिंग आप इस पर प्रैक्टिस
कीजिएगा ओके
चलिए और यहां पे चेक फॉर हिडन
डायरेक्टरीज वजन अपडेट नॉट देन फाइंड
एक्सम आरपीसी रर बस्टर चेक फॉर ट्रस्ट
फाइंड एक्सप्लोइट सर सीएस ना तो कितने
पैसे नहीं है सर सीच सर्टिफिकेट करने इतने
पैसे नहीं है तो क्या क्यों करना है जब
पैसे नहीं है तो क्यों इतना टेंशन लेना है
साइट के सबसे पहले नर्मल यूजर की तरह
विजिट करना सारी पेजेस एंड पॉइंट्स नोट
डाउन करने के बाद फेज जो है एक्चुअली इट्स
चेंज डिपेंडिंग न बिल्कुल सही बिल्कुल सही
अप्रोच है
शमीम दोनों तरीके से आप ट्राई आउट कर सकते
हो लाइक देखो किसी भी यूजर किसी भी
वेबसाइट को जब आप ब्राउज करते हो तो आप
किसी भी यूजर की सॉरी किसी भी वेबसाइट की
देखो एक तरीका है सिंपल सा तरीका है देखो
किसी भी वेबसाइट को आप एक नॉर्मल यूजर की
तरह पहले पूरा ब्राउज करो हर एक
फंक्शनैलिटी को देखो उसके फिर एक
रजिस्टर्ड यूजर की तरह ब्राउज करो रजिस्टर
करो उसपे अगर साइन साइन अप का ऑप्शन है तो
रजिस्टर करो उसके फिर फंक्शनैलिटीज को
एक्सप्लोर करो देन ट्राई करो कि एक नॉर्मल
यूजर की तरह जब आप उसपे जस्ट विजिट कर रहे
हो तो उसके कौन-कौन सी फंक्शनैलिटीज को उस
टाइम पे आप एक्सप्लोइट करने की कोशिश कर
सकते हो एक रजिस्टर्ड यूजर की तरह विथ लो
प्रिविलेज आप कौन-कौन सी पर्टिकुलर उसपे
एक्सप्लोइट करने की कौन सी चीज आप एक्स
ट्राई कर सकते हो आप उस पर्टिकुलर नॉर्मल
यूजर को कैसे आप एस्केलेट कर सकते हो टू अ
सुपर एडमिन और एडमिन यूजर या हाई
प्रिविलेज यूजर की तरह कैसे उसको कर सकते
हो कि नहीं कर सकते हो ठीक है तो ये सारी
चीजें आपको करनी है देन आपको डायरेक्टरी
ब्रूट फोर्स करनी है सब डोमेन फाइंड करना
है आपको अ सब डोमेन न्यूमरेशन आपको पूरी
की पूरी कर लेनी है फिर अलग-अलग वलने
बिटीज के लिए एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन हो गया
आपका सीआरएस हो गया आपका सीएसआरएफ हो गई
आपकी एक्सएसएस हो गया आपका इन सब के लिए
चेकआउट करना है इन सब की एक चेकलिस्ट बना
लेनी है चेकलिस्ट बनाने के लिए आपकी हमारी
जो वीडियो सीरीज है वो काफी हेल्प करेगी
आपको वीडियो सीरीज में जितने टॉपिक्स है
वो सब तो चेकलिस्ट में डालो ही इसके अलावा
और भी जो लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स हैं जो और भी
छोटे-छोटे वनबिल है उनको ट्राई आउट करो सस
ओस का चेकलिस्ट डाउनलोड कर लो उसमें बहुत
डिटेल में दिया हुआ है ऐसे आपको इंटरनेट प
बहुत सारी चेकलिस्ट मिल जाएंगी उन सब
चेकलिस्ट्स को शॉर्ट करो समरा इज करो एंड
अपना एक परफेक्ट चेकलिस्ट बनाओ जो जो उनके
अकॉर्डिंग होगा जो स्किल्स तुम्हारे अंदर
ऑलरेडी डेवलप्ड है ऐसी चेकलिस्ट मत बनाओ
जो चीज तुम नहीं जानते हो अब तुम्हें अगर
एसटीटी प स्मगलिंग नहीं आती है तो उसको
चेकलिस्ट में मत डालो उसको हटा दो कोई
जरूरत नहीं है भाई वहां तक जाने की जाओगे
धीरे-धीरे जाओगे अभी जाने की जरूरत नहीं
है तो उसको तुम उसमें इंक्लूड मत करो जो
चीजें आती है बस वही चेकलिस्ट में इंक्लूड
करो और चेकलिस्ट ऐसा बनाओ कि
लोअर सीवियरिंग वाली जो वनबिल है विथ लेस
सीवीएसएस स्कोर वाली वनबिल से हायर की तरफ
बढ़ते हुए बनाओ ताकि आप थोड़ा पहले
छोटी-छोटी चीज चेक करो फिर आगे बढ़ते
बढ़ते बढ़ते बढ़ते बड़ी चीज चेक करो ठीक
है कुछ टाइम पहले की बात है
एक बंदे ने एक्सेसेस फाइंड किया था सिंपल
सा ग का एक फंक्शनल था उसको एक्सप्लोइट
करके तो चीजें अभी भी है एजिस्ट करती हैं
अलग-अलग डेवलपर्स जो होते हैं कोड पुश
करते हैं अलग-अलग चेंजेज लाते हैं जिसकी
वजह से व बिलिटी अराइज होती है एंड उस
पर्टिकुलर को अगर तुम पकड़ के पकड़ लेते
हो तो फिर पकड़ लेते हो पकड़ लेते हो तो
फिर तुम मतलब मस्त तुमको जो है वैलिड बक्स
मिलेंगे तो तुम्हारे ऊपर डिपेंड करता है
ठीक है
सब भूल गया सर मैं ओल्ड वीडियो देख रहा
हूं भूल इसलिए गए क्योंकि प्रैक्टिस नहीं
है प्रैक्टिस नहीं रहेगी तो सब भूल जाएंगे
ठीक है हां जी बताइए ऋषि दस बताइए
जी सर बिगनर्स के लिए ट्यूटोरियल वीडियो
बनाया है तो काइंडली बोलिए कैसे
एक्सप्लोइट करें एक्सप्लोइट वेबसाइट प
एक्सप्लोइट वेबसाइट प भैया पहले व बिलिटी
तो फाइंड करो यार बग तो फाइंड करो
एक्सप्लोइट तो तब जब उस अब एक्सेसेस जो
तुम फाइंड करते हो उसमें क्या एक्सप्लोइट
करोगे उसको तुम चेन अप करोगे उसको तुम चेन
करोगे लो से हाई में करोगे एक्सेसेस से
दूसरे वटी हाय सिरिटी की वटी में ट्राई
करोगे जाने का जहां एक्सप्लोइट की जरूरत
है वहां एक्सप्लोइट करना है वहां पर थोड़ी
सी चीज अब एक्सप्लोइट वाली पार्ट थोड़ा सा
हम लेकर आएंगे लाइक हम एक्सप्लोइट का भी
सेशन रखेंगे लाइक काइंड ऑफ जब हम थोड़ा
एडवांस की तरफ बढ़ेंगे तो हम फुल
एक्सप्लोइट पार्ट पर भी आएंगे तो वहां पर
भी आपको पहले अभी बिगिनर्स की तरफ जाओ ठीक
है रियल वर्ल्ड में डी मोटिवेशन होता है
हां यह बात तो सही है डिमोटिवेशन होती है
करेक्ट बात है लगे रहोगे तो नहीं होगी लगे
रहो ट्राई हैक मी पूरा कर लो भाई ट्राई
हैक मी को छोड़ो मत मैं बता रहा
हूं आई एम टेलिंग यू नेवर ठीक
है चलिए ठीक है बढ़िया सो ट्स इट गाइस है
ना चलिए
तो आज की सेशन को यहां प
बंद करते हैं सब मेरे क्वेश्चन का आंसर
दीजिए कौन सा क्वेश्चन है
भाई टाइप ऑफ क्वेश्चन इ
दिस क्वेश्चन कहां किया था यार क्वेश्चन
तो ऊपर चला जाता
है मैंने क्वेश्चन का आंसर दिया होगा ना
देन क्या बोल रहे हो ये क्या बोल रहे
डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन समझा नहीं यार
तो ढूंढ ली एक्सप्लोइट एक्सप्लोइट तो करना
पड़ेगा भाई लेबिलिटी ढूंढ लोगे एक्सप्लोइट
का तो थोड़ा दिमाग तो थोड़ा लगाओ अब
एक्सप्लोइट के लिए तो पूरा सेशन लेना
पड़ेगा आपका प्रॉपर और एक्सप्लोइट के लिए
एक स्पेसिफिक अब मैं वही चीज शुरू करना
अभी चाहता नहीं हूं क्योंकि अभी हमारा चल
रहा है बेसिक बेसिक से इंटरमीडिएट चल रहा
है जब एडवांस पार्ट आएगा तो हम वहां तक भी
आएंगे लेकिन मैं नहीं चाहता कि आप अभी
प्रैक्टिस छोड़ो प्रैक्टिस छोड़ोगे तो
आपकी गलती है फिर वो फिर उसमें मैं कुछ
नहीं कर सकता यू जस्ट ट्राई आउट कीप
प्रैक्टिसिंग ठीक है आपको सब चीज मिलेंगी
आपको टेंशन नहीं लेना है ठीक है सब समझ
जाओगे भाई थोड़ा सबर करो थोड़ा दिमाग लगाओ
दिमाग के घोड़े को दौड़ा
थोड़ा ठीक है चलिए गाइस देन चलिए तो आज की
क्लास के लिए बस इतना ही धन्यवाद
बहुत-बहुत आप लोग सभी लोग यहां पर आए एंड
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में बहुत जल्द
एंड नेक्स्ट सेशन बहुत जल्द लेकर आएंगे
कुछ अलग टॉपिक एंड कुछ अलग चीजों को करने
वाले कवर करने वाले हैं एंड उसको हम देखने
वाले हैं ठीक है सो मैं एक ऐड इंसर्ट कर
देता हूं इसी बात पे धन्यवाद गुड नाइट
सबको एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में तब
तक के लिए टाटा एंड बाय बाय गाइस एवरी बडी
बाय बाय